WELL LOOKS LIKE I GOT THE GO
AHEAD DESPITE HAVING THE PERSON
HERE. WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
TODAY APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO I'D LIKE TO
REMIND THE PUBLIC THAT FOR THIS
IN FUTURE HEARINGS TESTIMONY
WILL BE IN PERSON WE ARE NO
LONGER USING THE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. WE ALSO
ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
OUR COMMITTEES WEBSITE. WELL
FIRST COVER THE GROUND RULES FOR
TODAY ASSEMBLY IT HAS EXPERIENCE
A NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS
COMMITTEE AND FLOOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. CAN
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUDER THREATENING
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. TAKING LONGER
THAN TIME ALLOTTED EXTENDED
DISCUSSION MATTERS NOT RELATED
THE SUBS OF THE HEARING A BILL
OR ANY OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I
WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS IF
IT INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS ARE
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM.
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN THE REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DESTRUCTIVE-
CONDUCT I MAY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING. IF THE
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP THE
REQUESTED SYSTEMS THE SERGEANTS
IN ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITAL. OKAY LET'S GET THE
BUSINESS HERE. WE HAVE SEVENTEEN
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY ONE OF
THESE ITEMS HAS BEEN PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA. TWO OF OUR
AGENDA ITEMS ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. ITEM TWO AB EIGHT
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN. ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD. IN ADDITION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WILL BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN. WILL
HERE ALL OTHER BILLS IN ORDER
SHOWN ON OUR AGENDA UNLESS
OTHERWISE NOTED. WE WILL TAKE UP
TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THESE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. ALL
SUBSEQUENT WERE WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO WISH A HAPPY
ADMINISTRATIVE PROFESSIONALS
DAY. TO ALL RE MADE WITH
MINISTRY OF STAFF WHO KEEPS THE
WHEELS TURNING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ESPECIALLY RECOGNIZE
OUR COMMUNITY. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY MARIE SOLANGE OF
CHESTER FOR ALL HARDWORKING
GREAT GRATITUDE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY WE ARE GOING TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE THERE'S
NO QUORUM RIGHT NOW OUR FIRST
ITEM ON TODAY'S AGENDA IS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MEDICARE AND THANK YOU
MANY MEMBERS- OF THE GOVERNMENT.
SB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS A.
IN BRIEF SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE
SHOULD I START AGAIN OR IS THIS
FINE. K. IN BRIEF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE IS A CLEAN UP BUILT
TO LAST YEAR'S AB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
PROVIDES RATE REDUCTION BONDS
AND FINANCING FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
ELECTRIC UTILITIES WHICH SHOULD
ALLOW THEIR CUSTOMERS TO SAVE
MONEY WHEN FINANCING MAJOR
UTILITY PROJECTS. THIS BILL
SIMPLY PROVIDES CLARITY AROUND
RESOURCES C. P. CFA CAN EMPLOYED
TO PERFORM THIS STATE REVIEW
PROCESS AND ENSURE THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RESEARCH IS NEEDED
TO DO SO. THIS BILL PROVIDES A
SLIGHT CHANGE TO LAST YEAR'S
BILL BY PROVIDING THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE SPECIFICALLY
THE CPC FAA A CALIFORNIA
POLLUTION CONTROL FINANCING
AUTHORITY CLEAR LANGUAGE
REGARDING ITS ABILITY TO CHARGE
PROPER FEES FOR THESE BOND
REVIEWS. AS THE BOND PRODUCTS
ARE NEW IN THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE NOR CP CFA HAS THE
EXPERTISE TO ISSUE THESE BONDS
BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE OUTSIDE
EXPERTS WILL ENSURE THE REVIEWS
ARE DONE PROPERLY. MAINTAINING
AFFORDABLE ELECTRIC RATES IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE WILL MAKE THIS TOOL
EVEN MORE USEFUL BY HELPING TO
KEEP ELECTRIC RATES AFFORDABLE
AND COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE THIRD
OF. IN IN THE LINE OF BILLS-
WHICH I STARTED SINCE MY FIRST
TERM IN OFFICE TO ALLOW FOR RATE
REDUCTION- PROCESS TO HELP SAVE
COSTS IN WATER- ELECTRICAL AND
SEWAGE- PURPOSES OF WITH ME
TODAY IS CASEY O'CONNOR
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
TREASURY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AS WELL AS SHEILA
TOBIAS DANIELS WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF C. P. CFA
TO ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF
THERE SHOULD BE ANY. PERFECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS THE I'M CASEY OKAY
TREASURE MAS LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AND SHE IS VERY PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THE- CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA POLLUTION
CONTROL FINANCING AUTHORITY ALSO
KNOWN AS CP CFA WE WANT ME TO
SAY THAT WHOLE NAME THEM OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. SO AT THE STATE
TRIES SUPPORT AB SEVEN SIX REFER
IN HER CUP AS THE CHAIR C. P.
CFA. AND ENSURE THAT WE THE
TOOLS AND I TO VERIFY RATE
REDUCTION BONDS AS- BY EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT I DO WANT TO
START OFF BY THANKING THE CHAIR
IN HER COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH US. IN ON THIS WE HAVE THE
CHANCE TO COLLABORATE TO ENSURE
IMPORTANT GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT
HAPPENED AS INTENDED BY AB SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT ANY AMENDMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE HELP ENSURE THAT WILL
HAPPEN. LIKE ALL PRUDENT ISSUERS
OF SECURITIES CPC FAA SEEKS TO
OBTAIN A SPECIFIC DIRECTION
NEEDED TO ENGAGE WITH SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO FULFILL ITS
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER THE
EXISTING LAW. AND DESPITE SI PC
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
SUCCESSFUL CONDO ISSUANCES OF
TAX EXEMPT BONDS FOR SOLID WASTE
DISPOSAL WATER FURNISHING AND
SEWAGE TREATMENT FACILITIES CBC
OF PHASE EXPERIENCE AS ALSO THAT
OF THE ISSUER. SO CBC OBEYING
THE STREET TRADERS OFFICE
CURRENTLY DO NOT MAINTAIN THESE
LEGAL OR FINANCIAL PERSONNEL
WITH. EXPERTISE REQUIRED TO MEAN
FOR FILL THESE REQUIREMENTS NOR
DO INDUSTRY STANDARD HAVE
UNIVERSE. REPORTER CALLS FOR AN
ISSUER OR STATE AGENCY TO
PROVIDE SUCH A DETERMINATION. SO
CBC THEY JUST SEEKS TO OBTAIN
THAT. DIRECTION TO ENGAGE WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
FULFILL ITS RESPONSIBILITY. AND
FOR THESE REASONS I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
THERE AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE AFTER ALL THESE
YEARS. AND WITH ME TODAY AS A
MEMBER NOTED AS SHE LOOKED VICE
DANIELS WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THE PROGRAM RECEIVE THE CFA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT.
CONCLUDES THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
. YEAH THANK YOU. ANY SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM. THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THE
OPPOSITION THE ROOM. THANK YOU
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE
ARE NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
. PLEASE OF NOT HAVING ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THE BILL I THINK IT'S
JUST VERY FITTING THAT I GOT TO
PRESENT TODAY BECAUSE I THINK AS
I WAS SITTING HERE THIS WAS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE ROOM THAT I MADE
MY FIRST PRESENTATION ON MY VERY
FIRST BILL- NINE YEARS AGO SO-
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERAND- WE WILL GET TO THAT
VOTE ONCE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA- TAKE THE
NEXT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS ITEM
TWELVE A. B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR. GREAT THANK YOU AND I
THINK MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS A GAP
OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO STRUGGLING LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS AT ANY
GIVEN NIGHT. WELL THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BEARISH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS A LACK OF PUBLIC
FUNDING WHICH I HAVE ANOTHER
BILL FOR. LAND USE POLICIES ALSO
THAT. LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF UNITS
THAT CAN BE BUILT. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE BYE MISTER DAVID CHIU
AMENDED STATE BONUS LAW TO ALLOW
1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS UNLIMITED DENSITY
FOR DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN. ONE
HALF MILE OF THE MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP OR HIGH QUALITY BUS
CORRIDOR. AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR BILLS ON RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS TO AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE BY ALLOWING A 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
TO RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE. FROM THE LOCAL AGENCY
ADDED HEIGHT AND UNLIMITED
DENSITY IF THE PROJECT IS
LOCATED IN URBANIZED VERY LOW
VIA T. AREA. THE BILL DEFINES
VERY LOW V. IN TWO AREAS AN
URBANIZED AREA WHERE THE
EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT- GENERATES VMT PER
CAPITA THAT IS BELOW 85% OF
EITHER REGIONAL V. M. T. PER
CAPITA OR CITY VMT PER CAPITA.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH WILL BE
RELEASING MAPS WITH REGIONAL
DIEM TO CALCULATIONS AT THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION LEVEL IN THE COMING
MONTHS. THESE MAPS ARE BASED ON
LOCAL TRAVEL DEMANDS. DEMAND
MODELS- DEVELOPED BY
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE PRODUCED
THEIR OWN MAPS OF THE THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND FOR
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS BY
INCREASING. THE UNIVERSE OF
SITES AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE
ALSO DESPERATELY NEEDED ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IS EMORY MAN OF THE
HELLO HOUSING CONSORTIUM AND THE
VADA MERRIMAN WITH MID PENN
HOUSING. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WEARING A
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WERE NON
PARTISAN ADVOCATE FOR THE
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION OF
HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME AND
CALIFORNIANS. DESPITE THE
LEGISLATURE DEMONSTRATE
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO FACE A
SHORTFALL OF OVER ONE MILLION.
HOMES AFFORDABLE TO THE STATE'S
LOWEST INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR
ADDRESSES THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AND FOR
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS BY
INCENTIVIZING INFILL DEVELOPMENT
INTENSIFICATION OF URBAN IS.
URBANIZING COMMUNITIES. THAT MAY
NOT YET HAVE HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT BUT OFFER CONVENIENT
ACCESS TO JOBS RETAIL AND
SERVICES ALLOWING RESIDENTS TO
DRIVE LAST TO REACH THEIR DAILY
DESTINATIONS. NOT ONLY IS VMT
REDUCTIONS CRITICAL STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVING OUR STATE CLIMATE
GOALS. IT ALSO PROVIDES OTHER
HEALTH EQUITY AND- BENEFITS THE
AS A LEVY EIGHTY TRAFFIC CAN.
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION. PROVING
LIKE HOW AND SO THE PACE GEN.
AND DISPLACEMENT WHICH IS WHY
ENVIRONMENTAL IN EQUITY GROUPS
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. AB TWENTY THREE THREE FOUR IS
CRITICAL TO HELPING WITH CLOSER
TREMENDOUS AFFORDABILITY GAP AND
ENSURE THAT LOWERINCOME
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
STABLE AFFORDABLE PLACES TO CALL
HOME IN EVERY COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE STRAIT STATE. AND TO HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR SEAS CLIMATE GOALS
AND FOR THESE REASONS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. OKAY THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF MID
PENN HOUSING CORPORATION. AT MID
PENN WE OWN AND MANAGE OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND AFFORDABLE ENTAL
APARTMENTS AND HAVE A%
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE OF NEARLY
FIVE THOUSAND ADDITIONAL HOMES.
ABOUT ELEVEN COUNTIES. INCLUDING
THE SAN FRANCISCO MONTEREY BAY
AREA. AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR PICKS UP WHERE ANOTHER BILL
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE CHIU
LEFT OFF IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
THAT BILL WAS THE FIRST TO ALLOW
1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS HAVE NO LIMITS ON
DENSITY AND UP TO THREE
ADDITIONAL STORIES AT THE
DEVELOPMENT WAS LOCATED. WITHIN
ONE HALF MILE OF A MAJOR TRANSIT
STOP OR HIGH QUALITY BUS
CORRIDOR. LAST MONTH MID PENN
BROKE GROUND ON KEY TO CROSSING
AN INNOVATIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY ENVISIONED TO SERVE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND OTHER SPECIAL
NEEDS POPULATIONS INCLUDING MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THIS WAS AMONG THE
VERY FIRST DEVELOPMENTS TO BE
ENTITLED USING AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY THREE INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. Q.
CROSSING WAS DEVELOPED AND DEEP
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF SAN
MATTEO AT THE TIME LAND THAT'S
OWNED BY THE CITY. CEMETERY WAS
EXCITED TO UTILIZE THIS NEW
ENHANCED DENSITY BONUS AS THEY
HAVE A HUGE LOCAL NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOMES BUT LIMITED
SITES THAT ARE UNDER CITY
CONTROL TO DEVELOP. CEMETERY
BROUGHT THIS OPPORTUNITY TO MID
PENN AND EMBRACE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL AS A
TOOL AN IMPORTANT TOOL THAT
WOULD HELP THEM MAXIMIZE A
SCARCE AND PRECIOUS. RESOURCE
PLANS. IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
PREVAILING WAGE JOBS FOR THE
FORTY BUILDING TRADES AND
MEETING AMBITIOUS SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS WITH ITS ALL ELECTRIC
APPROACH. THE REVISED
ENTITLEMENT PACKAGE WITHIN THE
AD OF SIXTY ONE HOMES FOR A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE. WITH SUBMITTED AND
PROCESSED QUICKLY WITH THE
PROCEDURE STILL REQUIRING
DISCRETIONARY ACTION BY THE
CITY'S PLANNING AND CITY COUNCIL
PLANNING COMMISSION CITY COUNCIL
. THE CITY THE COUNCIL PROVIDED
THEIR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND WAS
PROUD BEYOND MEASURE FORMER SAN
MATTEO MARY JO GOETHALS SAID IN
A STATEMENT WE HAVE OVER TWO
THOUSAND UNITS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE. AND WITH
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY THAT MID
PENN THIS BUILDING WE'RE
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERY INCOME LEVEL. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR BUILDS ON THESE
IMPROVEMENTS BY ALLOWING ALL
LOCATION EFFICIENT 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
TO QUALIFY FOR THESE ENHANCE
DENSITY RULES. THANKS DAN THE
BIG SPENDING THIS DENSITY BONUS
PROVISION TO LOVE THE EMPTY
AREAS AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR. BUT A LOT MORE COMMUNITIES
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
CRITICAL TOOL JUST LIKE SAN
MATTEO DID. AN INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
AREAS THE OFF THEIR CONVENIENT
ACCESS TO JOBS AND- RETAIL.
SERVICES ALLOWING OUR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS TO DRIVE LESS THAN
REACH ALL THEIR DAILY
DESTINATIONS AND THIS AT. THE
CHECK DALY THIS NATION'S AND THE
STATE TO REACH ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS. FOR THESE REGIONS
REASONS I URGE YOU TO VOTE I
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTAMENTS OF
HORTON THANK YOU SOME OF MEMBER
WICKS- FOR THIS- BRING. GEN IS A
ANY OTHER SENSE OF. AND IN THE
HERE ROOM. HOWEVER MANY DAYS IS
THE WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON EHALF OF SPUR SAND HILL
PROPERTIES AS WELL AS FEELS DEAD
AND COMPANY. STEVEN SAYS IT WITH
BROWN STEEN ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
ACTION COALITION SUPPORT. MARCUS
ALL THE ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. CURRENT CREDIT CARD
HARD ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ME
IN SUPPORT. SYDNEY PHANTOM HAVE
A BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
ADAM BRIANNA'S CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. ANY IN OPPOSITION
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YUP HALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
DO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
A POSITION ON THIS BILL- WE'VE
HAD. PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF. ON THE
DIRECTION THIS BILL WOULD YOU
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BACK
TO VERY LOW VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. WHICH WAS THE ORIGINAL
DEFINITION IN THE BILL. LAST
YEAR TWO YEARS AGO. LOOKING
AROUND LIKE SHE KNOWS- SO
THAT'S- WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT-
WE JUST REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MAPPING IT OPR- IS WE'VE-
TAKEN WITH THE MAPPING PROGRAM
THERE- IT. DOES OVERLAY- CITIES
A LOT OF A LOT OF A CITY CAN BE
OVERLAID OF THE OPR MAPPING AND-
NOT NECESSARILY HALF MILE FROM
TRANSIT. SO WERE- HOPING TO GET
YOU THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
COMMITTEE HOUSING COMMITTEE
STAFF- THIS WEEK STAFF ON THIS-
BUT RIGHT NOW WE ALSO WE ARE
STILL IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STATEMENTS MANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS CAUGHT
COMMISION COMMITTEE. C. NINE YOU
MAY CLOSE GREAT I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TALKING TO OPPOSITION
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET TO GOOD
PLACE AND RESPECT THAT FOR NAY
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- WE ARE IN A
SUBCOMMITTEE NOW BUT WE'LL HEAR
THE BILL ONCE WE MOVE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE-
QUIRK-SILVA. CRISTINA GARCIA AB. NINETEEN TEN. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
FACILITATE THE CONVERSION OF
MUNICIPALLY OWNED GOLF COURSES
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OPEN
SPACE. THE HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ARENA NUMBERS IN
DISCIPLE ARE VERY SCARY IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHERE
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL SPACE TO
BUILD HOUSING. I'LL BE BRIEF
ACTUALLY- THIS BILLIS
PERMISSIVE IT DOES NOT MANDATE
THAT ANYONE NEEDS TO DO ANY
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO DO ANYTHING
OR ANYTHING CONVERT THEIR GOLF
COURSES BUT FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE WERE ALL WE HAVE LEFT OUR-
BROWNFIELDS OR GOLFERS IS TO
LOOK AT IT ALLOWS US TO HAVE AN
ENGAGE IN. ENERGY TO THE SIDE OF
THIS IS THE BEST USE OF OUR LAND
USE UP THERE ARE NOT AMENDMENTS
IN THE BILL TODAY BUT I HAVE
BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS- TO NARROW
THIS BILL. I TO COMMUNITIES
WHERE SENSE AT THIS IS NOT A
SOLUTION FOR EVERYONE SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO LIMITED IN AREAS WITH
CERTAIN POPULATION DENSITIES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT TO LOOK AT- TO
LIMIT. GOLF COURSES THAT ARE
UNDER UTILIZED- AND THOSE
DETAILS ARE TO BE DETERMINED
BASED ON ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS AND LIMITED TO
AREAS THAT ARE ALSO CONSIDER
PARK POOR WE WANT TO OPEN UP THE
SEASON FOR BOTH HOUSING AND REAL
OPEN SPACE THAT. CAN STOP AND
DOES NOT HAVE A FEE TO ENTER OUT
THERE. ARE AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT WITH
THE AGREEMENT THAT THAT WILL BE
DECIDED AND WE WILL WORK WITH
COMMITTEE BEFORE- SUSPENSE FILE
HAPPENS- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. VOTE
THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JORDAN PUT
ON A KIND OF A HOT. LET'S HAVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA BE HERE
TO SUPPORT TALK IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TEN. CALIFORNIA ME THE
STATE WHERE DECISION OF OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND NEIGHBORS. THAT
THEY CAN TO MAKE OUR SAY
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE WORK
AND RAISE A FAMILY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THE MOST RECENT
STATEWIDE HOUSING ASSESSMENT
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE BELLAMY. ASM.
YOU NEED FOR HOUSING FIRST HERE
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS HOUSING
PRODUCTION AVERAGED FEWER THAN
EIGHTY THOUSAND NEWS HOMES EACH
YEAR AND ONGOING PRODUCTION
CONTINUES. TO BE FAR FAR FAR
BELOW THE PROJECT IN THE TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS. THE
COMBINATION OF HOUSING SHORTAGE
IN THE RISING RENT BECAUSE
CREATES INEQUALITY IT LIMITS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MIDDLE AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TO FIND A HOME.
AB NINETEEN TEN WOULD TRUST THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE BY SALVAGING A
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT WANT TO COME
VERY GOLF COURSE ON. BY THE
LOCAL AGENCY INTO HOUSING A
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE.
THIS BILL TAKE A ONE STEP CLOSER
TO ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE. BY EXPANDING THE
AVENUES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES. I
WOULD HIGHLIGHTED THIS PROGRAM
IS VOLUNTARY AND IS AT THE
DISCRETION OF EACH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DECIDE HOW OR EVEN
IF TO USE THIS NEW TOOL. THIS
BILL WILL NOT MANDATE ANY LOCAL
ENTITIES IT SIMPLY GIVES THEM
ANOTHER TOOL TO BUILD MORE
HOMES. CALIFORNIA IS BEHIND
SCHEDULE IN BUILDING MORE HOMES
AND WE BELIEVE THIS BILL. COULD
BE ONE OF THE SOLUTION TO GET US
BACK ON TRACK. WE RESPECT YOUR
QUESTION YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN TEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M SHOWING
DRAKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION AND THE
COMMISSION ALSO SUPPORTS THIS
BILL PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE FOR TO
POLICY PRIORITIES FOR THE STATE
AS WELL AS TWO PILLARS OF THE
COASTAL ACT THE STATUTE THAT
GUIDES THE COASTAL COMMISSION-
THE COASTAL COMMISSION IS
MINDFUL OF THE RECREATIONAL
ASPECT OF GOLF AND WERE EQUALLY
COGNIZANT OF THE LARGE AREA
REQUIRED FOR COURSES. THE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATING AND THESE DAYS OF
COURSE THE WATER REQUIRED TO
KEEP OF COURSE GREEN IN PROPERLY
MANICURED THAT BEING SAID WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AS THE AUTHOR
DID THAT AB NINETEEN AND DOES
NOT COMPEL CONVERSION OF
MUNICIPAL GOLF COURSES AND IT
DOES NOT PROHIBIT REDEVELOPMENT
INCLUDE. THE BILL. YOU CONSIDER
REDEVELOPING A MUNICIPAL GOLF
COURSE AND MAKES IT MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR THAT
REDEVELOPMENT TO INCLUDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND PUBLIC
OPEN SPACE THE GRANT FUNDS
PROVIDED BY THE BILL COULD HELP
DEFRAY THE MANY COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH REDEVELOPMENT SUCH AS
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSES REZONING
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THIS
WILL REDUCE THE COST BARRIER FOR
ME PALLIPES WISHING TO EXPLORE
REDEVELOPMENT OPTIONS THAT
INCORPORATE AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OPEN
SPACE INCLUDING POTENTIALLY
INNOVATIVE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
THAT ARE ENERGY AND WATER
EFFICIENT. OVERALL IT'S BILLS A
MEASURED APPROACH TO ADVANCE
SEVERAL STATE PRIORITIES ARE
PRESERVING LOCAL CONTROL FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
. IN THE ROOM. ADAM REALNESS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHERS.
SEEING NONE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP. NEED TO CREATE.
OPPOSITION SIR WITH THE- YOU CAN
SET UP YOUR FREE LIKE. HELLO
UNABLE TO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY I'M ANYMORE
MINISTER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR GOLF ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WIDE
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES THE
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION GOLFERS
IN CALIFORNIA THE ALLIANCE IS
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB NINETEEN TEN
AS NOTED IN THE DETAILS LETTERS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON MARCH THE
THIRTIETH WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHY THIS BILLS EVEN BACK IS THAT
VIRTUALLY IS IDENTICAL TO ITS
PREDECESSOR AB SIX SEVENTY TWO
WHICH FAILED TO CLEAR
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE AT THE
END OF JANUARY. BUT IF I MAY
HAVE A FEW POINTS I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE AB NINETY TEN
CHERRY PICKS GOLF. MUNICIPAL
GOLF COURSES FOR SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING WHAT ABOUT ALL THE OTHER
USES IT PARTICIPATE ARGUES
PUBLIC GOLF COURSES WHERE THEY
NOT INCLUDED WHY IS GOLF SINGLED
OUT. THIS BILL FAILS TO ADDRESS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS WHICH
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED IN DETAIL ON
OUR LETTER TO YOU ON MARCH
THIRTIETH. AND LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
COURTS. MUNICIPAL GOLF COURSES
ARE INDEED CONSIDERED A PARK
USE. THIS BILL RAISES CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PUBLIC SURPLUS LAND
ACT THE PUBLIC PARK PRESERVATION
ACT IN MARCH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND EXPRESSED ITS
OPPOSITION WE CONCUR. WITH THEIR
PREMISE QUOTE THIS BILL WOULD
JUST EMPOWER MORE CITIES TO
IGNORE THE SURPLUS LAND ACT AND
MONETIZE THE PROPERTIES AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE EVEN IF IT'S NOT
WHAT THE COMMUNITY WANTS. THE
TPL CONCLUSION GOES TO THE HEART
THE PROBLEM THIS BILL CREATES
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES THAT LEAD
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
SMALL GOLF PROPERTIES WERE
RESIDENCES ALREADY MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEIR PREFERENCES FOR GREEN
SPACE PARKS AND RECREATIONAL
SPACE. IF APPROVED IT WOULD
DRAMATICALLY. DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE GREEN SPACE OF
COMMITTEES- ALREADY IDENTIFIES
PARK PARK LASTLY THIS BILL
PROMISES HOUSING GET IT SEEMS
MENTAL. ON THE SIDE AND THIS IS
UNDER PER. ABOUT GOLFING IN
DECLINE NOT TRUE GOLF UNDER
UTILIZED NOT TRUE HERE THE FACTS
THE CALIFORNIA IS NOT THE OFFICE
NOT DECLINED QUITE THE NATIONAL
GOLF FOUNDATION TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. MORE PEOPLE PLAY THE
GAME OF GOLF IN CALIFORNIA THAT
EVER BEFORE. GULPING UNDER
UTILIZED NOT TRUE THE NGF ALSO
REMINDS US THAT TODAY WE ARE
SHORT GOLF COURSES WE WOULD BE
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MORE GOLF COURSES JUST TO MEET
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. THIS IS A
FAIR. AND A CLEAR FAR ANOTHER
MISNOMER PUBLIC GOLF COURSES ARE
NOT TYPICALLY SUBSIDIZED. AT IT
THEY'RE NOT EVIDENCED BY FISCAL
REPORTS PROVIDED BY DISABILITIES
WILL CITED IN A REPORT SUBMITTED
TO. PUBLIC GOLF COURSES IN MANY
CASES ACTUALLY HELP SUBSIDIZE
OTHER PARK PROGRAMS AND CLOSING
ONCE YOU CHOOSE DEVELOPMENT OVER
GREEN SPACE AND PARKS AND TAUGHT
START TOSSING DEVELOPER REBATES
IT OPENS THE DOOR TO PIECE
MEALING. IT IS NOT PRUDENT
PLANNING. THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD
NOT BE **** RUSHED INTO PASSING
THIS BELOW PAR LEGISLATION
PLEASE DON'T JEOPARDIZE
CALIFORNIA'S GOLF COURSE ISN'T
GREEN SPACE THEY'RE NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER ONCE GONE ALWAYS
GONNA. FOR THE REASONS I SHARED
ABOVE AND MORE THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR GOLF AND THE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE IT
SERVES IS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
NINETEEN TIME WE URGE YOU TO
STOP SPELL AND IF YOU DON'T MIND
BEFORE GOING TO FOR THE RELATING
TO US DOLLARS AT FORUMS WILL BE
ABLE TO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
AGUIAR-CURRY THERE. THAT'S IT
LACKEY BLOOM HERE BLOOM PRESENT
BOERNER HORVATH PROBLEMS RAMOS
PRESENT THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS PRESIDENT BUSH FELL
YOU VOEPEL PRESIDENT YEAH OKAY
WE HAVE A FORM IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BEGIN AGAIN I'VE I APOLOGIZE.
THEY YOU MADAM CHAIR AND OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M ALSO SET A MOTHER
NOVEL THE FOUNDER OF THE LATINO
GOLFERS ASSOCIATION AND A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBER SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOLF ASSOCIATION. THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL LAW THE
FACT THAT AB NINETEEN TEN ONLY
AFFECTS MUNICIPAL GOLF COURSES
THEY SAY IT LIKE IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE A GOOD THING. TERRIBLES
AND I THINK COULD BE FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH THESE ARE
COMMUNITY PARKLAND GOLF COURSES
WERE WORKING CLASS WOMEN AND MEN
AND YOUTH RECREATION TODAY AND
WORSE IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
ELIMINATING ANY ROADING OTHER
PARK AND RECREATION SPACES WERE
WORKING FOLKS PARTICIPATE IN
HEALTHY OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES.
LOCALLY OWNED COMMUNITY GOLF
COURSE WERE CREATED BY FORWARD
THINKING ELECTED OFFICIALS SO
THAT WORKING CLASS PERSONS COULD
THAT HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY ONLY
AVAILABLE TO THOSE WHO COULD
AFFORD PRIVATE CLUBS. I WISH I
COULD SPEND MORE TIME HERE
EXPRESSING WHY THIS BILL HAS HAD
A CHILLING EFFECT ON GROUPS LIKE
OURS WHO WORK AT THE GRASSROOTS
LEVEL TO OPEN THE DOORS FOR
WOMEN VETERANS IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR YOUNG AND OLD TO ENJOY THE
BENEFITS OF GOLF. OUR NUMBERS
ARE GROWING EXPECT SURELY WE
HAVE SHARED WITH YOU WERE
THREATENED BECAUSE OUR WORK
TAKES PLACE AT MUNICIPAL GOLF
COURSES OR DEVELOPMENTAL
PROGRAMS ARE WELCOME. I WAS
RAISED IN PUBLIC HOUSING SO I DO
GET IT I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I HAVE LIVED
IT BUT THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO
GET US THERE. IT PROMISES SCANT
HOUSING AT A VERY HIGH COST IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT AND VIOLATES THE SPIRIT
OF THE PUBLIC PARK PRESERVATION
ACT LAWS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS WISELY CREATED TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE ELIMINATION OF GREEN
SPACE IN CALIFORNIA'S URBAN
AREAS. WHAT AB NINETEEN TEN DOES
DO IS OPEN A PANDORA'S BOX OF
POWERFUL FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
SMALL CITIES AND DEVELOPERS JUST
SIMPLY DO WHAT THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND HAS SUGGESTED
COLLUDED TO VIOLATE THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT IN OPPOSITION OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHICH- LEAVE. THEM
HAVING TO FILE EXPENSIVE
LITIGATION TO PROTECT THEIR
INTERESTS LITIGATION. ENERGY OUT
OF. OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BREAKING
GENDER AND CALL BEAR THROUGH
GOLF PLEASE DON'T SHUT THE DOOR
TO US AND NOTE AT THE EIGHTY
FOUR OPPOSITION LETTERS LISTED
IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE STAFF REPORT MORE THAN
ONE THIRD OR FROM WOMEN'S
SENIORS JUNIORS AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR GOLF CLUBS. AND
ORGANIZATIONS I HUMBLY ASK YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB NINETEEN
TEN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
WELCOME A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
ON YOUR AMENDMENTS. RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE
THAT'S OPPOSING THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. JUST YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION. JIM PERRIN
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA LINES FOR
GOLF WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERE ANYONE ELSE. SEEING
NONE- ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE YES SOMEONE WITH
JUST SOME COMMENTS ABOUT TRYING
NOT TO RAMBLE- WHEN I WAS MAYOR
OF MY CITY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
UNINDICTED I WANT CREDIT FOR
THAT. WE ONCE HAD A COUNCIL
MEMBER THAT WENT TO AGAINST
LITTLE LEAGUE FIELDS. TO BUILD
MORE LITTLE LEAGUE FIELDS HE WAS
NOT REELECTED. SO I CAUTION
EVERYONE WHO WILL HAVE A VOTE
HERE THIS IS KIND OF LIKE COUPLE
OF KIDS LITTLE LEAGUE FIELDS. N.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN FAILING FOR
MANY YEARS BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN MY HUMBLE OPINION
WHICH AIMS SO HUMBLE. I BELIEVE
THAT MAYBE EIGHT MAYBE SEVEN OUT
OF TEN BILLS THAT WE'RE BRINGING
FORWARD A KENNEL LIKE FEEL GOOD
BILLS YEAH WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING HERE'S A
NEW INNOVATIVE WAY TO DO IT. I
BELIEVE THAT THIS PARTICULAR
BILLFALLS INTO THE FEEL GOOD
FIELD AND IT WILL ACCOMPLISH
VERY LITTLE- IT WILL TAKE AWAY
THE OPEN SPACE I MEAN THESE
FOLKS MADE A LOT. POINTS WAY%
BETTER THAN I CAN BUT IN THE BIG
PICTURE THIS PARTICULAR BILL
ISN'T GOING TO DO DIDDLY. NETS
MY FINAL COMMENT MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLUE.
MADAM CHAIR AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING LATE ANTHOLOGIZED SET FOR
WALKING IN ON THE MIDDLE OF THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION- BUT AS I
THINK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
HAS ALREADY MENTIONED SHE AND I
HAVE- BEEN DISCUSSING THIS BILL
AND- AND I WANT TO THANK HER FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND LISTENING TO
MY CONCERNS- I EXPRESSED
CONCERNS. ABOUT SINGLING OUT
GOLF COURSES IN FACT I THINKI
VOICE THOSE CONCERNS AT THE LAST
HEARING ON THIS ISSUE-
ESPECIALLY MUNICIPAL GOLF
COURSES THAT SERVE AS IMPORTANT
RECREATIONAL AREAS FOR THE
PUBLIC SOMETHING THAT I CAN
UNDERSTAND- BUT AT. THE I HOPE
ALL OF YOU KNOW- ONE OF MY GREAT
PRIORITIES IN A BITING
PRIORITIES- SINCE I WAS ELECTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND I THINK ONE
OF THE REASONS I WAS SENT TO
SACRAMENTO WAS TO WORK ON THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND- TRY TO FIND
WAYS- WHICH- BY NECESSITY. HAVE
TO BE CREATIVE WAYS- OF TO
SOLVING THE- OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS. SO I WANT TO AGAIN THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR- HER MR NARROW
THE BILL. OF BASED ON THREE
CRITERIA THAT WE'VE AGREED ON A
ONE OF FIND OUT- GREED ON
OCTOBER SET OF. WE NOW NEED TO
AGREE ON THE METRIC. FOR THOSE
HERE. I'M AND THAT'S LIKE A BE
EASY- COMMITTEE TO A- DOING THAT
IN FAITH AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
IS. WELL R. THREE CRY TO WITH
UPON OUR ONE LIMIT TO- THE
AREAS- LIMIT LIMIT-
CONSIDERATION OF A GOLF COURSES
TO AREAS THAT EXCEED A CERTAIN
POPULATION DENSITY. WE HAVE TO
DETERMINE WHAT THAT DENSITY WILL
BE. WE WOULD ALSO LIMIT THIS TO
GOLF COURSES THAT ARE UNDER
UTILIZED OR UNDER USED AND AGAIN
THAT'S A TERM OF ART WE WILL
HAVE TO DETERMINE. WHAT THAT
MEANS- AND FINALLY- WE WOULD
LIMIT IT TO AREAS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED- A PARK POOR- AND
EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS AGAIN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO WORK
OUT. I DO HOPE THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO- A WORK THESE CRITERIA
OUT AND THE METRICS ALONG WITH
THEM AND- I- EXPECTED TO. WE
WILL HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO DO
THAT BEFORE THE SUSPENSE HEARING
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
THAT IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO WORK
OUT- THOSE CRITERIA THAT YOU
WILL PARK THE BILL- IF AND WHEN
WE DO WORK OUT THE CRITERIA THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE TAKEN IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THE AMENDMENTS IT
AGREED TO AN- THE AUTHOR IS
WRITING. A I WANT TO SAY THAT.
HOUSING IS A- A CRITICAL NEED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- MY
THINKING ON THIS IS THAT IF WE
HAVE GOLF COURSES THERE MAY BE
NONE. IF WE HAVE GOLF COURSES
THAT ARE BEING UNDER UTILIZED-
HOWEVER WE END UP THE FINDING
THAT- THEN PERHAPS THERE IS A
BETTER AND GREATER PURPOSE THAT
WE CAN PUT THAT LAND- I. IT'S
NOT THAT I WANT GOLF COURSES TO
BE UNDER UTILIZED BUT IF THEY
ARE THEN I THINK WE SHOULD
CONSIDER THEM- AFTER THIS YEAR'S
THE L. A. TIMES RAN AN EDITORIAL
AS YOU THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE
PROBABLY NO. URGING US TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT A CREATIVE
BILL- THIS IS- THE AUTHORS AT
ATTEMPT TO FIND A WAY TO.
PROVIDE FOR MORE HOUSING AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN HONOR-
THAT DIRECTION I THINK WE SHOULD
AND- AND NOT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE GOLFING PUBLIC.
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK WE
SHOULD DO. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I'M SURE YES
THIS IS MARIE MESSAGES FROM-
VERY BRIEFLY I CONCUR- WAS
SOMEONE NUMBER BLOOM AND I JUST
YOU THIS IS A TOOLS AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO. TO REPURPOSE
YOU KNOW DRAMATICALLY
UNDERUTILIZED GOLF COURSES YOU
KNOW I WANTED MY COMMUNITY THAT
IS SITTING THERE AND HAS BECOME-
NOT ONLY AN EYESORE BUT HAS
BECOME A SOURCE OF WEEDS AND- IT
HAS NOT BEEN REPURPOSED AND SO
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
CREATE. A VACANT IT'S JUST IT'S
A VACANT GOLF COURSE. TO RE THAT
CREATE A PUBLIC USE- THAT WOULD
BE A VERY ATTRACTIVE OPTION IT
DISTRICTS SUCH AS MINE THAT%
LACKS THESE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND- THESE- OPEN
SPACES FOR OUR FAMILIES AND SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE. AT THE ALL
THE WORK THOSE INTO THIS I DID
THIS AGAIN IS JUST A TOOL- AND-
YOU KNOW HOPE THAT- WE CAN COME
TO TERMS- AS- BLOOM- MENTIONS.
AND I HAVE BEEN MOVED WITHOUT.
THANK WE HAVE A OF FROM THE
SUMMER MEMBER RIVAS TO SAY VICE
IN BLOOM- I WILL DELIVER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO. THOMAS YEAH I WILL
BE A BRIEF IN MY CLOSING- NOT
ALL GOLF COURSES SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR REDEVELOPMENT AT IT
THERE'S A SPACE FOR LIKE ALL OF
OUR OTHER SPORTS OUT THERE AND I
THINK AS WE TALK ABOUT REFINING
IT AND LIMITING WHICH IS YOUR
READ DAILY TRANSFER BETTER. TO
BE BUT IT'S- SURE IN THE TIVITY
AND I THAT THAT WHERE WE'RE TO
GET TO BEFORE WE GET TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE I AND THAT'S MY
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THE THREE
ITEMS REALLY NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL- AND COMMITMENT HONOR
MY WORD BEFORE THAT SUSPENSE
FILE IS THERE ON THE THREE
PIECES THAT WERE OUTLINED I
THINK WE COULD HAVE A SPACE
WHERE GOLF. COULD LIVE AND IT'S
DRIVING IN SOME OF THE OFFICES
OF MY COMMUNITY AND ONE OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS DRIVING AND
SOME OF THE SPACES IN MY
COMMUNITY AND THERE'S A SPACE
WHERE IT'S NOT HAPPENING IN
THOSE LIMITS THIS IS WHAT I'M
HOME WE COULD BE CREATED TO PULL
UP OF ALL THE- BILL BE. WITHOUT
AND YOU SAID PLAY BASED A SOCCER
THAT MIGHT BE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH US
MEMBER AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE CAN STAFF AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE US MEMBER. COMMENTS
AND IDEAS AND I KNOW YOU CAR TO.
PROVE OVER TO APPROPRIATE AS A-
SO WE'LL FORTY SINK IN HEARING
THOSE. YOU KNOW SOME CITIES
ACCOUNT MAYES THIS IS TRACK WAY
TO DEVELOP NEW HOUSING. WITH
YOUR EFFORT THOSE CITY COUNCIL
AND CITY BOARDS CAN WEIGH THE
INTERESTS OF THE RESIDENTS IN
DECIDING WHETHER TO USE THIS OR
TOOL OR NOT. NOT BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY- MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I AKKI. MACKEY NO
BLOOM. BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH LODEIRO LOS.
RAMOS I RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL NO
VOEPEL NOW WE HAVE A FOUR TWO
RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE A FOUR TWO
AND WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
EVERYONE.
YEAH. ALL RIGHT ARE THEY GOING
TO ARM WRESTLE LOOKS LIKE- I'LL
TAKE NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. TAKE NEXT MONTH-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BUT AGAIN
YEAH GOOD THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON AMENDMENTS AND I AM
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX WHICH WILL ESTABLISH
THE HOUSING COST REDUCTION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO REDUCE OR
DEFER LOCAL IMPACT FEES FOR
QUALIFIED HOUSING PROJECTS
DESPITE MONUMENTAL EFFORTS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE HOUSING
PRODUCTION CONTINUES TO STAGNATE
IN LARGE PART DUE TO THE HIGH
COST OF BUILDING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES CAN
REPRESENT UP TO EIGHTEEN
PERCENT. OF THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH BUILDING NEW HOUSING THE
COST OR THIS COST IS ADDED
DIRECTLY ON TO THE COST OF THE
UNIT AND THE SHOULDERS OF THE
RENTER OR THE HOME OWNER AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX PROVIDES
TO VOLUNTARY OPTIONS. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FIRST AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH 50% OF
THE VALUE OF FEE REDUCTION
GRANTED TO AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECT AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
ALSO ALLOWS JURISDICTIONS TO
DEFERRED FEES UNTIL A HOUSING
PROJECT IS CONVERTED TO
PERMANENT FINANCING WHILE CHART
. STE THE STATE. WILL THE-
ACTIVELY PER DEVELOPERS WITH A
ZERO INTEREST LOAN AND ENSURING
JURISDICTIONS ARE MADE WHOLE
THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE COST OF
BUILDING HOUSING WHILE
SUPPORTING BOTH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. MY WITNESS
TODAY IS MEGAN- TOKUNAGA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND-
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS MEGAN
TOKUNAGA I MAY HOUSING FINANCE
SPECIALIST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. IN OUR
THIRTY YEAR HISTORY THE
PARTNERSHIP HAS PROVIDED MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED NONPROFIT AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS OF AND
HELPS TO CREATE THEM HELP THEM
CREATE OR PRESERVE OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND HOMES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
ROADMAP THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
PRODUCE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
NEW AFFORDABLE HOMES OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF ITS LOWER INCOME FAMILIES AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR INHIBITING
INCREASE PRODUCTION IS THE HIGH
IMPACT FEES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CHARGE ALL NEW
DEVELOPMENT TO ADDRESS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. A MARCH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT FROM THE
UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER FOUND
THAT DEVELOPMENT FEES FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
COULD BE AS HIGH AS SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT. THESE
IMPACT FEES ARE CLEARLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR THE BUILDERS OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES AS THEY
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE NEED
FOR SCARCE PUBLIC FUNDS MONEY
THAT COULD OTHERWISE FUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE HOMES. AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX ENCOURAGES CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO WAIVE OR REDUCE
IMPACT FEES FOR AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING BY CREATING THE
HOUSING COSTS REDUCTION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. TO REIMBURSE
THEM 50% OF THE VALUE OF FEE
WAIVERS OR REDUCTIONS GRANTED.
THE LEVERAGED LOCAL FEE WAIVERS
WILL RESULT IN COST SAVINGS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
IN ADDITION THIS PROGRAM WILL
ACTUALLY REDUCE STATE COSTS AT
STATE HOUSING PROGRAMS NOW AND
IT PAYING A 100% OF THE CITY'S
MOST OF THE TIME. WITH THE
SAVINGS THE STATE CAN INCREASE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOMES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. STEVEN SENSOR
BROWN SCENE AND A HALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RAISONNABLE
THIS COMPILER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OR ACTUALLY NEUTRAL
BUT WE REALLY WANTED WITH
KNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON HIS STAFF THE SPONSOR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR ADDRESSING
OUR CONCERNS SO THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT COMMENT. TIFFANY VAN OFF OF
BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE ON
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE ROOM OPPOSING THIS BILL.
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. SEEING NONE
ANYBODY WONDER ME TO. ALL RIGHTS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THE BILL- YES EXCUSE
ME THERE'S A SOME REMEMBER
VOEPEL. I HAVE A MINOR QUESTION
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
THEN A COMMENT BASED UPON THE
ANSWER WHO. MISTER. SO DOES THIS
INCLUDE. THE HOOKUPS FOR WATER
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION MR VOEPEL
AND WE ARE WORKING TO REFINE THE
LANGUAGE WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THE RIGHTBALANCE OF WHAT IT INCLUDES AND
WHAT IT DOESN'T AS OF RIGHT NOW
IT'S SIMPLY IMPACT FEES FROM THE
MUNICIPALITY SUCH AS A CITY A
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AN AGENCY AT
. AS YOU ARE YOU ARE WORKING
WITH SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THE RIGHT LANGUAGE
IN THERE. MADAM AND I AM DOING
EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET BEYOND A FEEL GOOD
AND ACTUALLY GET TO SOMETHING
THAT'S PRACTICAL AND PRODUCES
HOUSING ROGER THAT WONDERFUL
ANSWER MAY I CONTINUE FOR. ONE
MINUTE ABSOLUTELY. GREAT BILL-
IN. MY PAST EIGHT YEARS AGO THE-
SDSU OR LOCAL. WONDERFUL COLLEGE
DUE TO ANALYSIS OF. FEES IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY ONE CITY WHICH WILL
REMAIN UNNAMED HAD 46% OF THE
COST OF A HOUSE WITH THE FEES.
ANOTHER CITY WHICH I WILL TAKE
CREDIT FOR WAS A TWENTY. 7% THIS
PARTICULAR BILL DOES MORE THAN
I'VE EVER SEEN TO HELP. DO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR EVEN MAKE
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR GREAT
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. SING NINE WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM OF
BOERNER HORVATH AND THEY SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
SECRETARY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY LACKEY I
BLOOM BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I'M RAMOS. HELLO
SIGN THOSE RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL I WILL
TELL HI YOU HAVE SIXTY. BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO AWAY FOR THE COUPLE
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH TED ON
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOUNDS EVEN. WITH NUMBER THIS IS
STILL. THANK YOU FOR I DON'T SIX
AB NINE TWENTY FIVE. WELCOME. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'LL BE
BRIEF THAT'S OKAY WITH COMMITTEE
. I'M FINE THANK YOU. AB
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED NONCITIZENS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR COUNTY APPOINTED
POSITIONS- THIS WOULD WAIVE THE
VOTER REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT-
THAT WOULD ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED
NONCITIZENS THE- HOLD APPOINTED
POSITIONS AND THIS WILL OPEN UP
MANY OPPORTUNITIES JUST GET KIND
OF AN IDEA OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT WHO WOULD
BE IMPACTED WILL BE DACA
RECIPIENTS. A LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS PEOPLE WITH WORK VISAS
NONCITIZEN NATIONALS- LIKE PUT A
RECORDER OR OR OR OTHERS OR
ANYBODY WHO COMES HERE- AS A
FAMILY SO IT WOULD GIVE THE
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO GAIN MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY CALIFORNIA I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
VOTE. THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE A MOTION SO
FAR OR DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS- THIS IS AUTHOR
SPONSORED OKAY. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE-
MICROPHONE. SORRY MADAM CHAIR
NOT IN A POSITION ALEXUS GUSTER
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA MCCANN
POLICY CENTER EVERYTHING CAST
MEMBER CENTER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION- DO YOU HAVE ANY.
OTHER COMMENTS. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ANY COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE REASON RIGHT NOW I HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS I NEED A SECOND. A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES
BROUGHT RAMOS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THINK THE MANAGER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND RESPECTFUL
THAT'S RIGHT UP. OKAY THANK YOU
AND I REALLY DO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
ACCOUNT TO APPOINTED POSITIONS.
THERE ARE SO MANY MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WANT TO ASSISTANTSHIPS SELLS
TWO ONE SERVANT WHO SHOULD THEIR
SKILLS TALENTS WHO LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND DESERVE IT CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BENEFIT OF OUR
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL PLEASE OUR
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM. I BOERNER HORVATH- HARD
NO RUN. RAMOS I THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT RIVAS
CYBER. VOEPEL NOW YOU THREE MORE
THREE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A-
THEREFORE THREE AND WE'LL WAIT
FOR THE MISSING MEMBER. THE
STUFF. THIS IS A LIST WITH OKAY
. RIGHT MR ONE MEMBER. YEAH OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- YOU HAVE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB. TWO SIX FIVE
THREE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANKS. WE WERE ON. ONE NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE FIVE. OKAY SO BUT
NOT NOW ON AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
THREE NUMBER ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
IF THIS BILL IS A VERY SIMPLE
BILL IT WOULD ALLOW EIGHTY DUE
TO REJECT THE ANNUAL PLANNING
REPORTS PLAIN SIMPLE WHO WERE
TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
WE BUILD- THE BILL HE HOUSE
INTO THE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IT IF A CD SHOULD BE
PROJECT ONE OF THESE REPORTS IT
WOULD ALLOW FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I TO BEGIN WRITING
THE REASONS THAT THEY- THAT THEY
ARE INCONSISTENT WITH THE LAW-
SO BASICALLY IN SHORT THE
ABILITY FOR ATV TO BE TO REJECT
THE ANNUAL PLANNING REPORTS-
GIVE FEEDBACK TO THE LOCALS AS
TO WHY THOSE REPORTS HAVE NOT
MET- THE- THE READ THE CURRENT
LAW. AND IN THE END WE HOPE THAT
THIS WILL GIVE CONSTRUCTIVE-
DIRECTION TOWARDS THE LOCALS TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE FOR TOWARD
IMPLEMENTING. OTHER HOUSING
ELEMENTS. THANK YOU. EVERY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL EIGHT
OTHER SPONSORED- I WAS THERE
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. ANYONE FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE IT'S YOUR LUCKY DAY MR
SANTIAGO I RESPECT THAT BUT I
DON'T. SO LOOKING FOR RIGHT NOW
FOR AS ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST. SECOND
THE SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER
RIVAS. WHEN I CLOSE ANYMORE
THEY'RE NOT RESPECTED I FIVE A
MANAGER MEMBERS OKAY- THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR NOW WILL
BE SPORTING TODAY- THE MOST IS
THE PAST APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
NO BLOOM. HELLO I HARPER. RAMOS
RAMOS SIGNS RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
HI ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL NO NO
FOUR TWO NOT THE RIGHT NOW FOR
TWO OR A FOR THE MISSING MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WELL WE HAVE- SOME TIME
WHEN WE DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
- THE CAN SIGNALLER IS MISSING
THE TWO BILLS. HI THE NUMBER TWO
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS NAZARIAN ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD. WE HAVE A
MOTION. HELLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOM LACKEY MOVED ZERO SECONDS SO
RIO SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JAMES FROM. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY LACKEY I
BLOOM BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH
RAMOS. I WILL SIDE THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL HI SIXTY. VOTES OUT SIX
ZERO WE'LL WAIT FOR THE MISSING
MEMBERS- WE'RE MISSING SOME
MEMBERS TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO YEARS MR
LOW. HELLO THIS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM HE HAS THREE BILLS HERE
WITH US TODAY. ITEM NUMBER. AB
EIGHT HUNDRED ITEM- FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY FIVE FOUR BY I
AM SIXTEEN A. B. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY NINE AND FOLLOWED BY A.
B. THE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB. TWENTY EIGHT NINETY. START
WHEN YOU'D LIKE SIR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SENT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR HELP WITH
THE BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY THIS IS- AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY FIVE AND- I THINK
MENTIONED EARLIER CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IS
EXACERBATING ANOTHER URGENT
CRISIS. OF MANY OF THESE ISSUES
THAT WE SEE INTERSECT WITH ONE
ANOTHER BUT IN THIS CASE WERE.
ARE GOING TO TRY AND HELP WITH
TEACHER SHORTAGES OF AT THE SAME
TIME. RECENT DATA SHOWS THAT ONE
IN TEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
LOSING A FOURTH OF THEIR
TEACHERS SKYROCKETING HOUSING
PRICES AND STAGNANT SALARIES
HAVE MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
TEACHERS TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY TEACH.
pOFTEN HOVER OF THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING MAKING
THEM- MAKING TEACHERS ON QUALIFY
FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING BUT
UNABLE TO COMPETE FOR MARKET
RATE APARTMENTS IT'S A DOUBLE
WHAMMY. FORTY SIX OF THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
BUILDING EDUCATIONAL WORKFORCE
HOUSING TO ADDRESS TEACHER
SHORTAGES AND RETAIN STAFF.
UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL RESISTANCE
COMPLICATED BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESSES AND RESTRICTIVE ZONING
HAVE ADDED CHALLENGES TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ON DISTRICT OWNED
PROPERTIES. TODAY ONLY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SANTA CLARA UNIFIED
AND LA UNIFIED HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
BUILT HOUSING PROJECTS ON
PROPERTIES THAT THEY OWN. BOTH
DISTRICTS REPORTED STRONG
INTEREST IN THESE UNITS BY BOTH
TEACHERS AND STAFF BUT ALSO
REPORTED CHALLENGES AND DELAYS
IN GETTING THE PROJECT OFF THE
GROUND. TWENTY NINETY FIVE WILL
REMOVE BARRIERS THAT HAVE
HINDERED HOUSING PRODUCTION FOR
TEACHERS. THE MEASURE WOULD MAKE
HOUSING AN ALLOWABLE USE ON
PROPERTIES SCHOOL DISTRICTS OWN
IF THE PROJECTS MEET CERTAIN
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FIVE REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PRIORITIZE TEACHERS
AND THEIR STAFF FOR THESE UNITS.
AND ENSURES THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RETAIN THE PROPERTY.
BY EASING THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FIVE WILL HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONSTRUCTION AFTER
HOUSING TO MEET THE CURRENT
DEMAND ADDRESS TEACHING
SHORTAGES. AND HELP KEEP QUALITY
TEACHERS AND STAFF IN THE
CLASSROOM IT'S A WIN WIN WIN.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
JEFF BENSON WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
INITIATIVES AT THE CENTER FOR
CITIES AND SCHOOLS AT UC
BERKELEY GO BEARS. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE- AS THE
SEVEN MEMBER SAID I'M-
DIFFERENCE IN WITH THE CENTER
FOR CITIES AND SCHOOLS AT UC
BERKELEY AND WE ARE A POLICY
RESEARCH CENTER AT BERKELEY MADE
UP OF URBAN PLANNING RESEARCHERS
AND EDUCATION POLICY RESEARCHERS
I MYSELF HAVE A PHD IN URBAN
PLANNING AND WE STARTED THE
CENTER ABOUT ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
AGO AS A PLACE FOR THESE KINDS
OF CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN THOSE
INTERSECT WITH PARTICULAR LAND
USE AND BUILT ENVIRONMENT ISSUES
THAT AFFECT. FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN HOW THEY YOU KNOW
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN PLEASE OR STRUCTURE
OBSTACLE FOR THEM SO WE DO
RESEARCH ON WHAT OUR MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL POLICIES AND
PRACTICES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
COLLABORATE ON- WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND ANOTHER HAPPEN I
HAPPEN TO WEAR IS THAT I SAID ON
THE CITY OF BERKELEY'S PLANNING
COMMISSION SO I'M WELL AWARE OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ISSUES
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO LAND USE
AND HOUSING. THIS SIMILAR ASKED
ME TO SPEAK BRIEFLY- IN OUR ON
OUR RECENT RESEARCH WHICH IS.
THIS BIG REPORT WE DID WITH THE
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION AT BERKELEY THAT WAS
MENTIONED. RESEARCHERS AT UCLA
AT CITY LAB- ARCHITECTURE DESIGN
RESEARCHERS AND PROFESSIONALS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION- EDUCATION WORKFORCE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA DEVELOPING
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CAMPUS-
WHAT WE DID WAS WE EXAMINE THE
NEED ACROSS THE STATE WE LOOKED
AT HOUSING COSTS IN EACH COUNTY
AND WE LOOKED AT SALARIES AND
STAFFING ISSUES AND ALL NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE DID CASE STUDIES
ON THE FOR EXISTING PROJECTS
THAT THAT ARE ON THE GROUND- WE
SCANNED THE STATE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT INTEREST ON THIS ISSUE.
WE MAP ALL OF THE LAND THAT
PUBLIC CAPABLE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OWN IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAD
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE AND WE-
LOOKED AT SO DEVELOP ABILITY
ISSUES ON THOSE LAND AND THEN ON
THIS PLANS AND THEN WE LOOK AT
POLICY FINANCE AND OTHER
CHALLENGES FOR BUILDING
WORKFORCE HOUSING AND SCHOOL
PLANTS. I FOUND WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID AS YOU ALL
PROBABLY ARE WELL AWARE THERE'S
A REAL BIG CRISIS OF TEACHER
SHORTAGES ACROSS THE STATE- BUT
NOT ONLY THAT YOU KNOW THE OTHER
STAFF. AT PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE REALLY HOUSING
BURDEN- YOU KNOW A THIRD OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA WHO RENT. ARE
CONSIDERED RENT BURDENED THAT IS
THEY'RE PAYING 30% OR MORE OF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT- AND
IMPORTANTLY. THESE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND TEACHER
SHORTAGE CHALLENGES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
ALREADY DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS.
IN OUR STATE. SO OUR REPORT. HAS
VERY DETAILED ANALYSIS ON THIS
WE ALSO BUILT AN INTERACTIVE
WEBSITE IF YOU WANT TO GO LOOK
AT. HOUSING PRICES HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY TEACHER SALARIES
AND STAFFING ISSUES ON THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND DISTRICT LEVEL
YOU CAN DO THAT ON OUR WEBSITE-
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT A LOT
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS REALLY NEED
THIS AND THEY WANT THIS- AS HE
SAID THERE ARE FOUR
DEVELOPMENTS. ON THE GROUND- ONE
MORE OPEN UP THIS YEAR IN DALY
CITY AT JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. THERE AT LEAST TWO MORE
SOLID UNDER WAY AND SKATE A
STATE WE IDENTIFIED FORTY SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE'RE EXPLORING VARIOUS
STAGES OF FEASIBILITY- WE
RECENTLY PUT OUT A CALL FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THIS
ISSUE TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE THOUGHT WE
MIGHT GET. EIGHT OR TEN OR
TWELVE RESPONSES WE GOT FIFTY-
WE MAP THE LAND WELL WHAT'S
INTERESTING WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS THAT THEY
ALREADY OWNED LAND. RIGHT A LOT
OF IT'S BEING USED BUT SOME OF
IT COULD BE THE REPURPOSE FOR
SHIFTED AROUND. OR IT'S ARGUABLY
UNDER UTILIZED. THERE ARE ELEVEN
THOUSAND PROPERTIES ACROSS STATE
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES. SO THERE'S LOTS OF
INTEREST AND LOTS OF OPPORTUNITY
ON THIS LAND IN EVERY COUNTY AND
IT'S NOT JUST A COASTAL ISSUE.
WE FOUND IT IN THE RURAL AREAS
AS WELL WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
SURPRISING TO MYSELF AS A
RESEARCHER I'M MORE SO THAN I
THOUGHT IT WAS BUT THE ISSUE IS
A AS A FAMILY MEMBER SAID IT'S
REALLY COMPLICATED. AND AB TWO
TWO NINE FIVE HELPS TO LEAVE
SOME OF THIS COMPLEXITY- WE CAN
GET INTO SOME OF THOSE DETAILS-
BUT IT PROVIDES ASSURANCES TO
THE DISTRICTS ABOUT WHAT THEY
CAN'T BUILD BUT ALSO. ENSURES
YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REVIEW AND THAT THE
PROJECTS IT HERE TO LOCAL
OBJECTIVE DESIGN AND DENSITY
STANDARDS WHICH REALLY COMES
RIGHT OUT OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE PUT FORTH SO. I SEE A
LOT OF WIN WINS HERE AS YOU
SAID- THE HOUSING GOES FIRST TO
THE EDUCATION WORKFORCE AND
INSECT LEETO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
POSSIBLY BENEFIT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND ALSO THAT THESE
HOUSING UNITS THAT MIGHT BE
PRODUCED WOULD COUNT TOWARDS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARENA NUMBERS
WHICH EVERYONE'S LOOKING TO
THOSE RENUMBER CERTAIN. BERKELEY
IS- SO I THINK THE BILL STRIKES
A REALLY INTERESTING BALANCE IS
REALLY AN ALLIANCE WITH THE
FINDINGS OF THE RESEARCH THAT WE
DID THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM FOR SUPPORT. ON AB TWENTY
TWO NINETY FIVE SO. YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION. FURTHERMORE WITH
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. ADRIN
MOHAMMED WITH LIGHT HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF BILLS THAT
AND SPARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR ANYONE ELSE THIRTY ONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL- WE
DID SIGNAL TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN THIS BILL CAME OUT
OF HOUSING BASED ON THE- HOUSING
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. DESCRIPTION
OF THE AMENDMENTS. THAT MAYBE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET A NEUTRAL
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER LOOKING AT
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND PREVENT. WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION WAS AMENDED- WE-
THINK THAT THE HOUSING MINISTER
VERY GOOD THINGS AS DESCRIBED
HERE- TODAY- BUT WE STILL DON'T
SEE A PLACE FOR OUR LOCAL
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCT. IS
LEADERS TO MAKE ACE. OF FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. LET ME
STEP BACK ON THAT FOR A SECOND.
THE REASON WE'RE HERE TODAY ON
THIS BILL AND OTHER BILLS AND WE
ARE HOUSING COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING ON THIS WEEK'S BILL. IS
THAT WHEN YOU. STREAMLINED THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS AND THE
PERMITTING PROCESS STATEWIDE.
THAT WELL SOMEONE ARGUE OF
SMOOTH THE PROCESS OUT FOR
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD- AND I THINK
WE ALL WANT THERE TO BE MORE
BUILDING BUT ARE ALSO TAKES AWAY
WAY POINTS FOR OUR LOCAL LEADERS
TO WAY AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHO ARE
GONNA BE DOING THE HOUSING
CONTEMPLATED BY THE BILLS SO
WHEN STATEWIDE LEGISLATION SUCH
AS THIS ONE OTHERS WE ASK FOR
THE USE OF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE SOMETIMES WE ASK TO
MAKE SURE CLEAR. THE PREVAILING
HE PAID. BACK TO THE BILL FOR A
SECOND IT PLAINLY STATES THAT A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
SHALL BE DEEMED AN ALLOWABLE USE
. WE BELIEVE THIS MEANS THAT
THEY'LL BE NO REZONING- WHICH
DOES TRIGGER SEQUEL. WHICH SOME
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM MIGHT BE
HAPPY ABOUT BUT AGAIN THAT'S
TAKES AWAY A SPACE FOR OUR LOCAL
LEADERS TO MAKE THEIR CASE FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. OTHER
PROBABLY BE NO DISCRETIONARY
PERMIT PROCESS- AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN IT WILL BE NOTHING IN
THE ZONING AND A LOCAL ZONING
ORDINANCE THAT REQUIRES A
PARTICULAR PERMIT FOR. SUCH
RESIDENTIAL USE ON THE OWNED BY
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCY- AND
WE ALSO JUST BELIEVE THERE'S AN
INCONSISTENCY IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE- SIX FIVE NINE ONE FOUR
POINT SEVEN- TALKS ABOUT. SAYS
SOMETHING SHALL BE DEEMED AN
ALLOWABLE USE BUT THEN RIGHT
BELOW THAT. IT SAYS IF YOU
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MEETS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS SECTION IT
SHALL BE DEEMED CONSISTENT. IS
IT DEEP IN ALLOWABLE USE OR
DEEMED CONSISTENT THERE'S SOME
INCONSISTENCY IN THAT LANGUAGE
THAT WE SAW COMING OUT OF
HOUSING COMMITTEE. SO AGAIN I
JUST WANTED TO STEP BACK AND
JUST REITERATE. WITH THIS IS A
GOOD IDEA WE HAVE OUR OWN
STUDENT HOUSING BILL IN THE
SENATE. TO PROVIDE STUDENT
HOUSING AT UC AND CSU CAMPUSES
WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN ISSUE.
WHEN YOU DO THIS TYPE OF
STREAMLINING- IT TAKES AWAY THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MAKE OUR
CASE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ASK FOR THE
LANGUAGE WE ASK FOR THIS BILL-
IN OTHER BILLS. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE DOING OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. SEEING NONE- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HEY I DON'T SEE ANY-
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WITH BILL A
SIMPLE RIVAS SECOND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR OFFICE I THINK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FINISHED STUFF
FOR WORKING ON WITH THE PHONES
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IT WAS A CONCERT
EFFORT AND I WILL APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE TRULY IS THE EARLY
AND ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND I WILL BE VOTING
I'VE TODAY. THE MOST TWO PASSES
INTO CREATIONS. OF HIS FELLOW
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
IRAQI. LACKEY NO BLOOM. HI BLOOM
I BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS FROM
THE SILOS RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS SIGHED VOEPEL NOT
NEARLY VOEPEL NOT VOTING YOU
HAVE A FOUR ONE CURRENTLY WE
HAVE FOUR ONE AND WE'LL WAIT FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I WILL NOT
DO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLEW UP THIS AGAIN. THANK YOU
CURRENTLY LAW REQUIRES
JURISDICTIONS TO IDENTIFY AT
LEAST ONE ZONE WITHIN THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT WHERE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS ARE PERMITTED BY RIGHT.
THE LAW HOWEVER DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE JURISDICTION TO DEMONSTRATE
SITES WITHIN THAT ZONE ARE
SUITABLE AND AVAILABLE FOR
SHELTER DEVELOPMENT OR HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MEET THE NEED. THE
RESULT IS THAT MANY
JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
PLANNING FOR SHELTERS OR OTHER
INTERIM HOUSING AND CREATING
BARRIERS TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EMERGENCY SHELTERS FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. IN
ADDITION CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THAT IF A JURISDICTION FAILED TO
REZONE ENOUGH LAND TO MEET ITS
RAINY AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
DURING THE PRIOR HOUSING ELEMENT
PERIOD. IT MUST MAKE UP THE
ZONING SHORTFALL IF I IN ITS
SUBSEQUENT HOUSING ELEMENT. THE
SITES RESULT TO MAKE UP THE
SHORTFALL FROM THE PRIOR HOUSING
ELEMENT ARE KNOWN AS CARRYOVER
SITES. THERE IS SOME AMBIGUITY
IN THE LAW AS TO WHETHER THE
STATE'S NO NET LOSS OWNING LAW
APPLIES TO BOTH CARRY OVER
SITES. AND SITES TO MEET THE
CURRENT RENO OBLIGATION AS A
RESULT SOME LOCALITIES MAY NOT
COMPLY WITH THE OBLIGATIONS TO
REPLACE CARRYOVER SITES THAT ARE
DEVELOPED WITHOUT HOUSING FOR
LOWER INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS FURTHER
CONSTRAINING. BADLY AT SITES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. EIGHT TWENTY
THREE THIRTY NINE WOULD
STRENGTHEN HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
TO ENSURE THAT ZONES IDENTIFIED
AS LOCATIONS WHERE SHELTERS AND
OTHER INTERIM HEALTHY SOLUTIONS
CAN BE BUILT BY RIGHT OR
SUITABLE. AVAILABLE AND
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FINALLY THE BILL
WOULD CLARIFY THE NOTE THAT NO
NET LOSS LAW APPLIES TO BOTH
CARRY OVER SITES AND SITES
IDENTIFIED TO MEET THE CURRENT
REINA. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND WITH A TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY IS ON THE
LAWLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TURN
MEMBERS OF ANOTHER AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY WERE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT I
THINK MISTER BLOOM LATER LAID
THE ISSUE OUT WELL LAW THE LAW
HAS LONG REQUIRED THAT
JURISDICTION'S CREATE BY RIGHT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SHELTER
DEVELOPMENT- BUT WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND OVER THE YEARS IS THAT AP
A SMALL SEGMENT OF
JURISDICTIONS. HAVE PUT THOSE-
IT SITES SERVERS OWNED. ZONES
THAT HAVE EITHER NO AVAILABLE
SITES FOR DEVELOPMENT AT ALL- OR
THAT ARE IN HEAVY INDUSTRIAL
AREAS OR OTHERPLACES THAT WOULD
BE REALLY INAPPROPRIATE FOR AT
THE LOCATION OF A SHELTER OR IN
FAR FLUNG AREAS THAT ARE NOT
SERVED BY TRANSIT ARE. CONNECTED
TO SERVICES BUT WHICH IS REALLY
NOT MEANINGFUL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST PUT US
MORE PARAMETERS AROUND THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY GET
REAL SITES THATTHAN A SHELTER
COULD LOCATE ON BY RIGHT BE
BUILT QUICKLY. TO HELP SERVE THE
INTRAMUSCULAR SPRINTING
HOMELESSNESS APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATION IN THE WORK WE WERE
ABLE TO DO ON THIS BILL WITH THE
COMMITTEE- AND WITH RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I DON'T. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON JAN CAN-
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE SINGLE IN THE
OPPOSITION. I SEE NO OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEVEN NINE WE HAVE A-
MOTION ENTERTAINING MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALL RAMOS SECOND SET-
CHECK CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- THIS BILL IS
PRETTY FAR DOWN IN THE WEIGHTS-
BUT LAST WEEK WE LEARNED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAT ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE DIED ON THE
STREETS OF LA WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- THAT
IS UP I THINK BY 56% FROM THE
YEAR BEFORE THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HUMANITARIAN
EMERGENCY AND EVERYTHING WE CAN
DO TO- HELP RESOLVE HOMELESSNESS
WE MUST DO AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE STEPS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR DESIRE TO
IMPROVE THE STANDARDS OF HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT TO THIS BILL- AND
TO AMEND THE BILL TO ALLOW
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTINUE TO USE
OVERLAYS OWNS IS ZONING
INSTRUMENTS BY DEFINING
EMERGENCY SHELTERS ALSO RE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY. LACKEY
NOT VOTING BLOOM I WILL I BURGER
YEAH. RAMOS BERNHARDT THAT NOT
VOTING RAMOS RAMOS SILOS RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SORRY
VOEPEL NOT VOTING THE BILL NOT
VOTING FOR THREE RIGHT NOW WE
ARE MORE WE ARE FOUR THREE AND
WE HAVE TO SCHOOL- JUST FORCE
USERS YOU HAVE I DIDN'T SEE THE
SIGN WE HAVE FOUR AND WE HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THE MISSING MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE PLAN
WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN. AB. TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY CLARIFIES
THE STANDARDS AND PROCEDURES
THAT PROPERTY BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT LEADERSHIP
AND ENGINEERS MUST USE WHEN
DETERMINING WHAT CONSTITUTES A
SPECIAL BENEFIT AND GENERAL
BENEFITS FOR PURPOSES OF
PROPERTY AND BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT BOARD KEEP
IT ASSESSMENTS. AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINE SIMPLY CLEARS UP AMBIGUITY
IN EXISTING LAW WITH RESPECT TO
THE BENEFIT IDENTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION
TWO EIGHTEEN WHICH IMPLEMENTED A
NUMBER OF NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
PEOPLE'S INCLUDING
IDENTIFICATION OF SPECIAL AND
GENERAL BENEFIT. THE INITIATIVE
INCLUDED ONLY BRIEF DEFINITIONS
OF SPECIAL AND GENERAL AND HAD
NO IMPLEMENTATION GUIDANCE FOR
HOW ENGINEERS ARE TO IDENTIFY
AND SEPARATE THE TWO BENEFITS.
THIS AMBIGUITY HAS MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
DETERMINE WHAT ASSESSMENTS CAN
BE CHARGED AND IT INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
DISTRICTS. A NARROW ADDITION TO
THE STREETS AND HIGHWAYS CODE IS
NEEDED TO GIVE DIRECTION TO
ENGINEERS AS TO HOW TO CALCULATE
THE ASSESSMENT BENEFITS AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY CLARIFIES
THE PROPERTY AND BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT LAW OF
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DETAILS TO
HELP PARTY'S COMPLY WITH THE
BENEFIT SEPARATION REQUIREMENTS.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES THE SPECIAL
BENEFIT OF THE PROGRAMS WHICH
WILL HELP PEOPLE AS SUCH.
UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY LEGAL
CHALLENGES WITHOUT THE
CLARIFICATIONS HE BIDS WILL
REMAIN SUBJECT TO LITIGATION
CHALLENGES THAT WILL SEVERELY
IMPEDE. ADVOCATES HAD AN
UNPRECEDENTED IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES AND AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY PROVIDE
SIMPLE CLARIFICATIONS THAT WILL
HELP ENSURE PEOPLE'S CAN
CONTINUE TO REVITALIZE OUR
STATE'S DOWNTOWN AREAS AND
ECONOMIC CORRIDORS IN TIME. WHEN
THAT THESE DISTRICTS NEED IT THE
MOST I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I'VE COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON SOME CLARIFYING AND
IT'S THAT ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. AND HERE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE THE SPONSORS JASON
BRYANT AND JOHN LAMBETH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION. WELCOME
THANK YOU MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF-
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO
BE SPONSORING A BILL- BIDS
IMPROVEMENT ENERGIZED THE
STATE'S URBAN AND COMMERCIAL
DISTRICTS BY FUNDING
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ENHANCE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND PUBLIC
SPACES THAT SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESS. WILL HELP STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS FOR HABITS ORGANIZE
AND MANAGE THESE DISTRICTS. AND
HOW THESE BENEFITS ARE FINANCED
AND PROVIDED BY THE BED. THESE
TO HAVE SUPPORT FROM A NUMBER OF
BEDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE FROM
SAN DIEGO TO NAPA AND MANY IN
BETWEEN- I'D LIKE TO TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE JOHN LAMBETH TO SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL- AND HOW IT WILL
IMPROVE THE PROCESS FOR BEDS.
THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
LAMBERT PRESIDENT CEO CIVITAS WE
ARE AUTHORED AT FANTASTIC JOB OF
DESCRIBING ALL THE DETAILS. I'LL
JUST FILL IN A JUST A BIT- AS HE
MENTIONED PROP TO EIGHTEEN
REQUIRES THAT ALL PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS INCLUDING. ITS
RECOGNIZE SPECIAL IN GENERAL
BENEFITS. AND UNFORTUNATELY
LANGUAGE IN THE CONSTITUTION
STATUTE IN THE COURT CASES HAS
LEFT AN AMBIGUITY AND THAT
AMBIGUITY. THREE PAVE THE WAY
FOR PLAINTIFFS TO COME IN AND
FILE CHALLENGES AGAINST THESE
DISTRICTS THREATENING THE WORK
OF THESE. EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO THIS BILL WOULD CODIFY
THE DECISION LEADING IT TO
EIGHTEEN K. SADDAM'S. VERSUS
DOWNTOWN MONA P. BIT IN
PARTICULAR CLARIFIES THAT THE
SERVICES AND IMPROVEMENTS ARE
THEMSELVES THE SPECIAL BENEFITS.
THIS CLARIFICATION ALLOWS HE'S
DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE TO FINANCE
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
ACTIVITIES. IN OUR DOWNTOWNS AND
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD. NICK
ROMANO BE HAPPILY OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES YOU THE OFFER AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING TO
REVITALIZE OUR DOWNTOWNS THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SAYING NONE OF IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SKOK OFTEN HARDER IS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR A WHAT IF
THEY'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH US
ON. AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE
WITHDRAWING OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALWAYS GOOD
NEWS. ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSING
THE BILL SEEING NONE OTHER TO
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
RIGHT NOW I HAVE A FIRST BY A
BURNER FOR FAR. AND THE SECOND
BY A MYSTERY MOST. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A MANAGER IF YOU
THOUGHT THE LAST BILL WAS DOWN
IN THE WEEDS I HAVEN'T HEARD
THIS ONE I HAVE AND I THINK I
MAY HAVE SET A RECORD FOR NUMBER
OF TIMES ONE CAN SAY P. BID. IN
A SINGLE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR IT AND I BE VOTING
ON. ON THE BILL TODAY THINK OF
EMOTIONS TO PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND WE- HI AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY. BLOOM HI ROOM AYE
BERMAN. BOERNER HORVATH I'M
RAMOS. RAMOS AND HIS THREE THIS
ROBERT RIVAS. VOEPEL THAT'S
PROBABLY VOEPEL NOT VOTING WE
HAVE FORCED. FOUR WE ARE FOR ALL
RIGHT NOW WAIT FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER
BLUE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORTERS. I WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE. AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY ONE MISTER BERMAN.
AND AFTER THAT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
REPRESENTING MR MULLIN TODAY AND
IF YOU DON'T MIND DOING THAT ONE
RIGHT AFTER DOES THAT WORK FOR
YOU THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VENTURE OKAY. WOULD BE.
MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES FOR I
WOULD LIKE WITH COMMITTEES FOR
THEIR WORK ON BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS DESCRIBING
THE ANALYSIS AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE WOULD REFORM THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION. VTA GOVERNMENTS
HAVE BEEN THE SUBJECT OF THREE
CIVIL GRAND JURY REPORTS OVER
THE LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN GRAND JURY
REACHED A SIMILAR CONCLUSION TO
THE ONE REACHED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WHICH WAS THAT BT IS
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE IS A ROOT
CAUSE OF THE AGENCY'S POOR
PERFORMANCE. THE GRAND JURY PTA
TO PROPOSE LEGISLATION TO
RESTRUCTURE THE BOARD ISN'T
INSTEAD STATUE. WHAT AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHT. IS BY ON TWO YEARS OF
STAY. IN BALL DO. I WORK CLOSELY
WITH CURRENT AND FORMER VTA
BOARD MEMBERS AND CONDUCTED
EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
INCLUDING HOSTING A PUBLIC VTA
GOVERNANCE REFORM TOWN HALL
EARLIER THIS YEAR. WE ANALYZED
DOZENS OF SIMILAR TRANSIT AGENCY
BOARDS THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE VTA
BOARD SELF ASSESSMENT. THE GRAND
JURY FINDINGS THAT WE PRIORITIZE
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION TO THIS EFFORT
LAST YEAR. OPERATING ALL THIS
FEEDBACK AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
ONE FOCUSES ON FOUR KEY AREAS
FOR. STABILITY TRANSPARENCY
REGIONALISM AND EXPERTISE AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE REPLACES
THE CURRENT BOARD WHICH IS A
ROTATING GROUP OF TWELVE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND SIX ALTERNATES IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WITH A TWELVE
MEMBER HYBRID BOARD COMPOSED OF
BOTH LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
QUALIFIED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
. THIS BILL EMPOWERS LOCAL TO
SELECT BOARD. WHAT PRIORITIZE
BOTH REGIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY AND
EQUITY IN USING A REGIONAL
RANKED CHOICE VOTING PROCESS FOR
THE SMALL CITIES. THE NEW VTA
BOARD MEMBERS WILL BE SELECTED
BY CITY AND COUNTY OFFICIALS IN
A TRANSPARENT PUBLIC PROCESS
ENSURING THAT EXPERTISE RELATED
TO TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT MANAGEMENT. FINANCE IN
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP ARE
REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD. IN
ADDITION AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
ONE LAN THINS TERMS FROM TWO TO
FOUR YEARS TO PROVIDE FOR
GREATER STABILITY. THERE ARE
MANY EXAMPLES OF SUCCESSFUL
HYBRID TRANSIT AGENCY GOVERNING
BOARDS WITH BOTH ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND APPOINTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCLUDING IN
PITTSBURGH BOSTON AND TORONTO. I
WANT TO WRITE. LAST FEW YEARS
VTA HAS MADE MEANINGFUL. SUCH AS
THE NEW CATTLE PENS PORTER. BUT
THE NEED FOR STROLLER FOR ME
IT'S INDUSTRY WHAT JUST IN. AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE IS THE
LACK OF CON. BLACK OF. AND LACK
OF EXPERIENCE AFFECTED THE VTA
BOARD FOR MANY YEARS WILL BE
BUILDING A SYSTEM OF REGIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. I DEFINITELY
WANNA AND SIZE THAT I'M OPEN TO
SUGGESTED IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS
PROPOSAL. AND I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE HIGH
QUALITY REPRESENTATION FOR ALL
SANTA CLARA COUNTY RESIDENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
MAYBE ONE EIGHTY ONE AND- AND WE
ME TODAY IS TREAT ON YOUR- R. J.
V. T. A. AND A FULL SANTA CLARA
. COUNCIL MEMBER. THANK YOU
WELCOME AND- THANK YOU CHAIR
AGUIAR CURRY VICE CHAIR LACKEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BROOKLYN'S BILL AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY ONE. I WAS A MEMBER
OF THE VTA BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY ALSO I HAD THE
HONOR OF SERVING AS CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR OF THE BOARD. AT THE
MEETING. WELL AS CHAIRED. ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THE BIGGEST ONE
WAS A GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF
THE BOARD I ASKED THE BOARD TO
WORK WITH ME TO DESIGN A
STRONGER BOARD ONE THAT CAN
FOCUS ON THE TREMENDOUS
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES IN SENECA
COUNTY AND ARE READ. I CONVENE
AN AD HOC BOARD COMMITTEE M. AND
THE SOURCE OF THE PROBLEMS. AND
FIND A BETTER WAY FORWARD WE
DEVELOPED A ROBUST LIST OF BOARD
ISSUES AND ENGAGED OUR OUTSIDE
AUDITOR CHEN TO HELP ANALYZE
THEM. WE EXAMINE BOARD
STRUCTURES A TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES AROUND THE UNITED
STATES. IN MY ATTEMPT AT
TRANSPORTATION CONFERENCE I
FOUND VERY FEW SUCCESSFUL
AGENCIES HAD PTA SUPPORT
STRUCTURE. THE RESULTING REPORT
DIDN'T MAKE A RECOMMENDATION ON
CHANGING THE BOARD STRUCTURE AS
THE AUDITOR GENERAL FELT THE VTA
HAD SO MANY ISSUES THEY WEREN'T
PUTTING A NEW BOARD STRUCTURE IN
PLACE WHAT. YEAH COMMITTEE. ON
CENSUS OF OR HONORING. TO THE
BOARD OR ON AN ALTERNATIVE
STRUCTURE. BELIEVE THE AD HOC
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT A POLITICAL PATH FORWARD.
I STILL WANT CAN VTA AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE PEOPLE OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WOULD BENEFIT FROM
A BOARD STRUCTURE SUCH AS
DESCRIBED IN AB TWENTY EIGHTY.
WITH THIS GOAL OKAY SPON
PHILLIPS AND IT'S LARGE BUDGET
WE NEED A BOARD VERY FOCUSED ON
VTA AND NOT HAVING VTA AS ONE OF
MANY ANCILLARY DUTIES. FOR MY
FIRST BOARD MEETING THIS VIDEO
CHAIR I WORK WITH STAFF TO PLACE
BOARD MEMBERS ON THE MANY TA
COMMITTEES WHEN I APPLY FOR THE
MEETING. STARTED HEARING WHICH
OF THE CITY BOARD MEMBER SEVEN.
VKA BY THEIR PEERS THESE
INCLUDED BOARD MEMBERS GOING TO
CHAIR COMMITTEES. WHAT MAYOR
COULD. V. T. ORDER TO PROTECT
PRO. PUT HIMSELF ON THE BOY AS
WAS FINE NEED TO RUN FROM OFFICE
HERE. LATER THAT YOU HE READ
FROM. INPUT PRIOR MAY BACK ON
THE BOARD. A COUPLE OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS GOT TEXT MESSAGES DURING
THE MEETING SAYING THEY WERE
BEING ON APPOINTED. ONE LEAD
OVER AND SAID TO ME HOW LONG
IT'S BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH YOU
AS THE START TO PACK. THANKS I.
WE HIS TAX THAT HOME I DIDN'T
YOU CAN'T NOW I TO PUT SESSION
AS HE WAS A STRAW VOICE AND NEED
A FOR CORE I CAN DO HIM TO STAY
FOR PART OF THE SESSION OTHERS.
THE STORE. ON AN ISSUE WITH A
BOARD. I DON'T TO BE COULD OF
THE BOY MEMBERS BUT THEY ARE
EITHER FULL TIME COUNCIL MEMBERS
ARE COUNTY SUPERVISORS OR PART
TIME. RECEIVE AND IT IS VERY
CHALLENGING FOR THEM TO GIVE VTA
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
ATTENTION. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY ONE TO PROVIDE V. T.
EIGHT WITH THE BOARD DEDICATED
TO PROVIDING THE BEST
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS FOR
SILICON VALLEY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF A FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
THE AUDIENCE. SEE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE OF THE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. IOTA
THEME I NEED A MOTION. HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS. OF WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST APPRECIATE THE
DOZENS OF CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
THIS BILL APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF OF DONE-
IN AGUIAR-CURRY AND- I
APPRECIATE THREE SERVER FOR
DRIVING ALL THE WAY UP AND WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE. WELL I
KNOW THAT CHANGING. THE
STRUCTURE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BOARD IS NOT VERY SIMPLE- PLEASE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL THE
REBEL AND STAKEHOLDERS AND MIKE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON FUTURE
AMENDMENTS. I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THE DAY AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TRAVELING UP.
ISSUE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI. LACKEY I
BLOOM. BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS. FROM
ASIDE THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
VOEPEL NAPOLI THE BILL NOT
VOTING YEAH FIVE. EARLY VOTERS
FIVE AND WE WILL WAIT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH
OKAY- I'M GOING TO NOW ASK YOU
TO DO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AND
RESPOND I'M SORRY BUT WE- IS
PRESENTED FOR MR MULLIN TODAY.
THIS SHOULD BE VERY QUICK- NEVER
SAID YEAH YOU KNOW HOW THAT
HAPPENS. AS A GREAT POINT
CORRECTLY JINX MYSELF SO THIS IS
OUR AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLINS. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO START WHEN READY
THANK YOU AND THE GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A BEACH SO.
EIGHT NINE. ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
REMOTE BILL THE I'M ALSO PROUD
TO CO AUTHOR A BEACH HE SAID
EIGHTY NINE A BILL THAT WILL
ALLOW HIM THE CHOI TWENTY THREE.
BUT YOU DESIGN OKAY FOR. PART
TRICKS UNDER THE LEGISLATION.
EXTENT FORTY TO THE EAST BAY
REAL PARK DISTRICT. IT ALSO
CLARIFIES THE TO OF DOES BILL
CAN BE FOR. TAYLOR FROM IT'S A
IMBIBE DISTRICT. LIMON ONE
TWENTY ONE SAID NOT ME. PULLED
BILL WITHIN THE TWENTY TWO FIVE
SUNSET FOR ALL LOCAL AGENCY.
THIS THIS ALLOW THE SPA FROM IN
THIS. FOR FURTHER IN THE WALL AS
PART OF A CO. ARE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- AND WITH ME TODAY ARE J.
C. LAN AND CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
WITH MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND LISA GORDON
CORRIGAN CORRIGAN. GORGE IN
COURT I HAVE OVER THE FIRST TIME
GORE CHEN CHIEF OF DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT WELCOME.
WELCOME TWENTY. YOU CAN OKAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEN BERGMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AGAIN I'M
CHASING LENT ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER WITH NOT
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN AS MID PENN
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN MET PAN
ANSWER CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY PARTICIPATED AS CO
SPONSORS OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE AUTHORED BY SENATOR JERRY
HILL THIS BILL AUTHORIZED TO
ENTITIES TO USE DESIGN BUILD
PROCESS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THESE AND
OTHER. IN ORDER TO HAVE ENHANCE
OUR RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
IT ALSO PROTECTED RESTORED
IMPROVE PARKS WILDLIFE OPEN
SPACES IN BEACH LANCE M. DEVELOP
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE PLANS YOU
STATE REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT AS
THE SISTER AGE ADDED. TO THIS
BUT- FISHERY THIS PROPOSAL. I
WILL GO INTO THE DETAILS IN PART
OF A DESIGN BUILD MATH. SUFFICES
DESIGN BILL REPRESENTS
OPPORTUNITY SECOND LEAD TO
OVERALL COST SAVINGS EARLIER
PROJECT COMPLETION IN A GREATER
ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND QUALITY
OF WORK ALL OF WHICH BENEFIT THE
TAXPAYER WHO IS PAYING FOR IT
AND SUBSEQUENTLY ENJOYING THE
USE OF THESE IMPROVEMENTS- THE
PLAN IS PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT EACH OF THE SUBJECT
ENTITIES WILL MAXIMIZE THE
UTILITY OF PUBLICLY TRUSTED
FUNDS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION AND ALL TURNED
OVER TO THE SPIRITUAL PART
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
MY NAME IS LISA GORDON I'M THE
CHIEF OF DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
AT THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT AS THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT LOOKS
TOWARDS MEETING THE STATE'S
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES WE WILL NEED MORE
TOOLS TO HELP ADVANCE
RESTORATION AND RESILIENCY
EFFORTS. THE BEST VALUE
CONTRACTING DESIGN BUILD TOOL
WILL BE A KEY PART TO ADVANCING
PROJECTS THAT WE KNOW WILL NEED
TO BE DONE TO ADAPT. MANY OF
THESE. PROJECTS WILL BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MULTI
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AS PUBLIC
AGENCIES WE ARE OBLIGED TO HAVE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE MEANS TO
DO THIS IMPORTANT WORK. AS
AGENCIES GUIDED BY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ETHIC WE ALSO NEED
TO WORK WITH CONTRACTORS WHO
RESPECT AND VALUE THE HABITAT
CONSIDERATIONS WHICH ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THESE UNIQUE
PROJECTS. WITH THIS AT THE
ALREADY THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT PLANS TO USE IT TO
CONTINUE TO DELIVER MULTI
BENEFIT CLIMATE FRIENDLY
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE ELEMENTS
OF PUBLIC ACCESS NOT. THAT
RESTORATION AND CLIMATE
ADAPTATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE AT
THE READY WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSOR
L. THANK YOU YOUR STAFF AND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FOR.
CALL QUERY WITH THIS CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ADRIN
MOHAMMED WITH LAST PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY ALSO KNOWN
AS VALLEY WATER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THREE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ARE THERE ANY TO ANYONE
HERE FOR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. SEEING NONE. OF THE- COMMITTEE
OF THE GUEST AUTHOR AS A GUEST
PRESENTER. THE MAN OKAY WE HAVE
BURKE PARTNER HARBAUGH
MEMBER LACKEY. IS THERE USED TO
SAY IT. THE FIVE- YES I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR READING
THE BILL FOR IT I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR HELPING OUT
MISTER MOLOT AND THIS IS A I
LIKE THIS BILL SO
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT THANK
YOU ANOTHER AREA. SECRETARY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY. LACKEY I HAD LITTLE.
BLOOM EYED. BOERNER HORVATH I
RAMOS. REBELS IDOLS RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS. THE RIGHT VOEPEL I. SIX YEAH THANK YOU MISTER YEAH
THEY WILL WAIT FOR THE- MEMBERS. YEAH. THANK YOU. WELL I HAVE
TO LAUGH PEOPLE HERE- YES WE
WILL ITEM NUMBER THREE AB EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE. THANK MISS PARKER. FOR TO.
HI RIGHT. REFER TO THIS REPORT.
WELCOME WELCOME TO ME THAT'S
WHERE WE HAVE BEEN GOING BACK
AND FORTH AFTERNOON SO OKAY I'M
HERE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I AM PRESENTING EIGHT
THREE POP STREAMS L. NOW WE GET
ALL THE OF A LOT OF OTHER NAMES
TO CALL THIS BILL BUT I'M NOT.
ALL THOSE ALL THOSE. BUT THE IS
USING THE RESTROOM FOR MOST OF
US WE USE IT AT OUR LEISURE AND
ANY PLACE THAT WE ARE FOUR TO
TEN TIMES A DAY DEPENDING ON THE
INDIVIDUAL. MOST OF US DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO FIND A RESTROOM TO USE
. BUT THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IT
NOT ONLY INCLUDING PARENTS OF
YOUNG CHILDREN SENIORS AND OF
COURSE MANY MANY HOMELESS THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT LUXURY WHEN THEY
HAVE. WHETHER IT'S A CHILD OR
THEMSELVES NEED TO FIND A
RESTROOM. BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE UNDERSTAND AND KNOW
THAT MANY RESTROOMS WERE CLOSED
WHETHER IT WAS- RESTAURANTS
RETAIL BUSINESSES WE'VE ALL BEEN
TO A PLACE OF BUSINESS IT SAYS
ONLY INCOME EARNERS. AND YET
THIS IS A BASIC BOTTLE FUNCTION
. NOW TO MAKE IT EVEN A LITTLE
BIT MORE EXTREME THINK OF OR
IMAGINE A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVING
IN ENCAMPMENTS FIVE THIS IS A
GOOD QUESTION IS WHERE DO THEY
GO. SO THIS IS NOW BECAUSE I
COME A SANITARY AND HEALTH
CONDITION AN ISSUE THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE SERIOUSLY SO WHAT MY
BILL WOULD DO IS SAY THAT WE
WOULD LIKE AND WE- ARE HOPING
THAT THIS YEAR WE CAN GET
APPROVED- A PUBLIC WEBSITE THAT
WOULD AT. LET DIVISION NO WHERE
A PUBLIC BATHROOM IS AVAILABLE
IT BY THE ZIP CODE- THIS BILL
WILL BENEFIT ALL PEOPLE
INCLUDING VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
SENIOR WOMEN GET WORK. OUR USER
THROUGH. AND OF COURSE ALMOST-
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES- A FAILURE TO
PUBLICIZE AN OPEN THESE PUBLIC
RESTROOMS HARMS OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY AND ECONOMIES WITHOUT
THIS INFORMATION SHOPPERS
TOURISTS AND OTHERS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO RETURN HOME OR TO
THEIR HOTELS AND BEST AND LESS
TIME IN OUR COMMERCIAL. QUARTERS
SO MAGIC. AND ARE NO. WE DEPEND
ON IS AND WE NEED OUR BATHROOMS
TO BE OPEN TODAY- WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS BY SIMPLY KNOWING
WHERE PUBLIC RESTROOMS ARE IN NO
WAY IF. MEET I'D TESTIMONY ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
MISTER RON HOTCH BOMB ESQUIRE AN
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF
LAW AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PACIFIC- MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW
IN SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU SEE
MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE EXPERT
TESTIMONY TO TODAY HI MY NAME IS
RON HAKAM I'M AN ASSISTANT
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF LAW AT THE
KEY OF THE PIECE. FIRST GLOBAL
DIRECT BECAUSE THE CLINIC. TWO
TWENTY AYE PUSHIN. ENTITLED BY.
AS RIGHT TO ISSUE. CONCLUDING
THAT THE BILL TO USE THE
BATHROOM AND PRIVATE. IS CENTRAL
TO OUR CONCEPTION OF HUMAN
DIGNITY AND THAT'S PRECISELY WHY
BATHROOM ACCESS HAS BEEN PART
EVERY CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
A LOT. IN THE MEDICAL
DISTINCTION. AND ACCESSIBLE OF
PUBLIC BACK BIG AVAILABLE
BATHROOMS IT ONES THAT ARE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT ARE OF
LIMITED UTILITY IF THEY ARE NOT
ACCESSIBLE ONE BARRIER TO PUBLIC
BATHROOM ACCESS IS THAT THEIR
LOCATIONS ARE POORLY PUP I JUST
GOT. PUBLISHED CENTRAL. CAN MAPS
PARKS. PUBLIC TRANSIT LINES
POLLING PLACES IN LIBRARIES BUT
BATHROOMS ARE NOTICEABLY ABSENT.
THIS IS PARTIALLY BECAUSE CITY
THEMSELVES ALMOST INVARIABLY DO
NOT MAINTAIN THE STATE OF. EIGHT
TEAMS EIGHTY THREE WOULD RATHER
BY THAT. PROMOTE BATH. FOR COME
THAT BY THE STORE AND- ARE
DENIED BATHROOM ACCESS SUCH AS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WOMEN
PEOPLE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
TRANSCRIPTOME AND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE
WHO MUST ACCESS BACK MS WITH.
FREQUENCY PUTTING YOURS. WOMEN
IS WHICH UP AND PEOPLE WITH
PARTICULAR MEDICAL CONDITIONS
AND PEOPLE WHO DO NOT WORK IN
OFFICES SUCH AS THE DRIVERS CAN
GET WILL. AB EIGHT IT WILL STEM
ECONOMY. HEALTH PROTECT WORKERS
AND CORRECT LEGACIES OF
DISCRIMINATION AT ITS CORE IT'S
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT ITS
PASSAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS THE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
AUDITORIUM. SO REAL. AFTERNOON
JAN CAN- WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MANY OTHERS THIRTY ONE HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE THAT THE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE.
COMMITTED TO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS C. NONE WE
AND I DIDN'T SOMEONE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
SECOND TICKET ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LUCKY FIRST ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
RAMOS SECOND. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST DON'T RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS THIS IS A
POLICY CONSIDERATION REYES BY
THIS COMMITTEE WHEN WE HEARD THE
BILL SIMILAR LAST YEAR A SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORT TO MAKE PUBLIC ABOUT
BATHROOMS- RESTROOMS. MARKS A
SYMBOL AND EASIER TO FIND. ALL
NEEDED ONE AND WE ALL LOOKED
AROUND SHOULD BE NICE TO HAVE AN
- TO FIND. OUT THAT YOUR NEXT
STOP- ARE WE VOTING FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY. MOTIONS TO PESTER
PROCREATION COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE FOLLOW AGUIAR-CURRY BY.
COOLEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I.
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS. I THE
QUESTION YES YES FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH I. RAMOS RAMOS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS WEBER
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL NOT VOTING
VOEPEL NOT VOTING. YOU HAVE FIVE
THREE WITH A CAREER FIVE ZERO ON
THE BILL CHANGED. OKAY I WILL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
ALSO SOME NEW MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
THAT AB. TWO TWO TWO ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB. TWO TWO
TWO ONE. A. D. U. ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT BILL. AB TWO TWO
TWO ONE WILL CLARIFY EXISTING
LAW TO HELP EXPEDITE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A D. YOU. ONE OF
THE SPOTS IN. HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE HAVE BEEN
VERY FEW BRIGHT SPOTS HAS BEEN
THE BUILDING OF A D. USE BECAUSE
SOME OF THE WORK DONE AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE HAVE NOW SEE MORE
PROTESTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A TWO BUILDING
EIGHTY USE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
ALONE WE HAVE SEEN A GOOD
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE- BILL DATE D.
WITH THAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN. PUSH
WITH MY SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE TRIED TO WORK
THROUGH THAT- WE KNOW THAT
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
ISSUES WITH HOUSING AND NOW WE
HAVE EVEN MORE. THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST RETURN A FULL SET OF
COMMENTS TO A PROJECT TO MOAN IT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF A
SUBMISSION OF AN EIGHT YEAR. NOW
EVERY MONTH IN FORMULA E'S
PROJECTS ARE EITHER DELAYED OR
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS TAKE
SOMETIMES THREE MONTHS NINETY
DAYS MORE THE PRICES GO UP TO
CONSTRUCT AN EIGHTY YOU- IT ALSO
SPECIFIES THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CANNOT EXCEED THE LIMITS ON
PLANNING STANDARDS FOR. OF
EIGHTY. OUR THE DEADLY NAY DID
IN STATE LAW I WILL JUST SAY ONE
OF THE CITIES THAT I WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE STATE SAYS THAT
YOU CAN BUILD AN A. D. U. N. IT
PATCHED GARAGE. WE'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN BUT IN A DETACHED GARAGE-
THE IN THIS PARTICULAR CITY THEY
HAVE SAID YOU CANNOT BUILD A NAY
D. U. AND A DETACHED GARAGE AND
THAT TO THE HOMEOWNER WOULD HAVE
TO BUILD ANOTHER GARAGE AND THEN
THEY COULD BUILD THE EIGHTY YOU
. SO THIS DOES NOT MAKE ANY
SENSE IN ACTUALLY THEN-
ENCOURAGES PEOPLE NOT TO BUILD
THE AD YOU SO THESE ARE SOME OF
THE- OOPS WE'RE SEEING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PUT IN. AND BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
WHERE THERE ARE SOME CITIES THAT
HAVE THE RIGHT RECIPE MEANING
PLANS THAT THEY CAN CHOOSE THAT
ARE ALREADY PRE APPROVED- FEES
THAT ARE SOMETIMES- HOW ON- IT
MEANING THAT THEY HOLD THEM SO
THAT YOU'RE NOT SEEN. AS FEES
PUT ON EIGHTY USE SO I THINK
THIS IS CLEAN UP BILL TO SOME OF
THE WORK WE'RE DOING AND- WE THE
TWO. SUPPORT OF THE NO WE HAVE-
LOUIS MOREAU TABLE KELLER. YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME'S LOUIS MONTANA LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA BE ONE
OF THE SPONSORS AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE. IF YOU DON'T KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS TO END CALIFORNIA'S
IMMENSE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOME SHORTAGE- WERE A PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH ORGANIZATIONS UP
AND DOWN AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE DOING THAT
WORK OUT IN THE FIELD TODAY THIS
BILL IS THE PRODUCT ONE OF THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. SINCE THE PASSAGE
EIGHTY WHAT HAS SPURRED THE
CREATION OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOMES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY THESE
SPECIALISTS AND HOMEBUILDERS
THESE HOMES HELP STABILIZE
HOMEOWNERSHIP CREATE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCORDING TO THE UC BERKELEY-
TURNER CENTER A RESEARCH
INSTITUTE PRODUCE HOMES THAT
RENT FOR UP WHAT WOULD BE
TYPICALLY AFFORDABLE TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE IN- THE MSAS IN
WHICH THEY'RE LOCATED THAT'S A
WIN WIN SITUATION FOR EVERYONE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I THINK THE
ANALYSIS DOES A GREAT JOB
LISTING THAT CHANGES THAT THIS
BILL MAKES WANTED TO THINK THAT
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
US TO MAKE SURE THESE ARE ALL
RIGHT. THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST RETURN A
COMPLETE SET OF COMMENTS ON THE
EIGHTY PROPOSAL WITHIN THE
TIMELINES DELINEATED UNDER STATE
LAW. THAT ALL RELEVANT PERMITS
AGENCIES MUST RETURN THOSE
COMMENTS. AND MORE CLEARLY
ENUMERATE THE ITEMS THAT A LOCAL
AGENCY CAN AND CANNOT REQUIRE OF
A PROJECT APPROVED UNDER SUB
DIVISION II OF EIGHTY LAKH WHICH
ESTABLISHES. THAT THAT THAT THE
SUBDIVISION THAT ESTABLISHES THE
RIGHT OF A HOMEOWNER TO BUILD.
HUNDREDS BUT DID YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ACCELERATE
THE SUCCESS OF EIGHTY LAKH I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE BEGIN I THINK YOU
TURN MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA FOR HAVING ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE EXPERT TESTIMONY ON
THIS BILL- MY NAME IS ANY FRYMAN
AND I'M IN. A COMPANY CALLED
ABODE YOU. BILL SAYS RICK UNITS
CALIFORNIA INDEED IN SERVING
HOMEOWNERS IN MANY OF YOUR
DISTRICTS- WE- HANDLE ALL THE
PERMITTING FOR HOMEOWNERS. AND
ADDITIONALLY DO A LOT OF CITY
EDUCATION AS WELL WHICH ACTUALLY
GIVES MY TEAM A REALLY UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON THESE RECURRING
TECHNICAL AMBIGUITIES. THAT
EXIST IN CURRENT EIGHTY YOU LAW
AND ACTUALLY WASTE A LOT OF
EXCESSIVE PUBLIC SECTOR AND
PRIVATE SECTOR RESOURCES. TO
INTERPRET- THE CHANGES IN THIS
BILL AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE.
ARE IMPORTANT CLEAN UP AND
TIGHTENING TEARS YOU ARE ALREADY
DID A LOT. THEY DO NOT
SUBSTANTIVELY X. EIGHTY LAW. ROB
YOU CAN CLEAR FOR CITIES
IMPLEMENTED NORMAL HOMEOWNERS TO
UNDERSTAND IF THERE PER THING
EIGHT ZERO. THIS SPEEDS UP
PERMITTED. IT REDUCES THE AMOUNT
CITY RESOURCES THAT NEED TO
SPENT ON CITY. I DINNER IS TO
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW. OUR TRIBE
AND- THESE ABOARD PERMIT ISSUES.
EACH PROVISION OF THIS BILL AND
I THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE IS ALIGNED WITH H. C.
D.'S CURRENT ADOPTED GUIDANCE OF
CURRENT LAW. IT ADDRESSES THE
CONFUSION AND HOW THE LAW IS
WRITTEN THAT CITIES IN
APPLICANTS HAVE REPEATEDLY
STRUGGLED TO INTERPRET ON REAL
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS- IT'S ALSO THE
FINAL OUTCOME THAT I'VE SEEN IN
CITIES AND APPLICANTS TO
MUTUALLY AGREE UPON AT THE END
OF THESE CONFLICTS. HIS IS THE
PROPER INTERPRETATION OF. AFTER
DIGGING IN FURTHER WITH THEIR
ATTORNEY H. C. D. AND SARAH AND
IT'S ALSO IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
ORIGINAL SPIRIT OF EIGHTY LAWS
AT THIS EXACT LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED IN RECENT YEARS- I DON'T
NEED TO GO OVER EACH. ONE IT'S
OF THE BELL. ALLUDES IN HIS
BIRTHDAY. BUT I DO WANT TO
MENTION THAT MY TEAM HAS
PERMITTED OVER ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY USE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND HAS COLLABORATED
EXTENSIVELY WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WITH EACH CD. TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA STATE LINE
GUIDELINES. HOPEFULLY WITH
CLARITY. AND CALIFORNIA CITIES
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND TRAINING
TO PROCESS THE IS EIGHTY YEARS
ACCORDINGLY- IN CONCLUSION I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU. A GREAT
REAL LIFE EXAMPLE OF THE
BENEFITS OF THIS BILL- IN THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS MY TEAM IS
HOW TO TROUBLESHOOT THE EXACT
SAME ISSUE. REGARDING WHICH
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS CAN APPLY
TO SMALL EXEMPTION EIGHTY USE
UNDER TODAY'S CURRENT LAW. THE
GUIDELINES IN EACH CD AND THE
STATUTE PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE HAVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF DETAIL ABOUT WHAT IS
X. CERTAIN DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS
THEY'RE NOT CONFLICTING BUT THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF DETAIL.
AND SO THIS CREATES A LOT OF
CONFUSION AMONG PLANNERS WERE
READING ONE DOCUMENT AMONG
ATTORNEYS WERE READING FIRST
ANOTHER DOCUMENT AND THEN
APPLICANTS ARE TRYING TO
NAVIGATE THE GUIDANCE THAT EXIST
OUT IN THE WORLD. IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE DOZEN
SITUATIONS WHEN WE ESCALATED THE
ISSUE TO H. CITY'S TECHNICAL.
UNIT TO PROVIDE NEUTRAL PARTY
PLEASE GIVE US THE RIGHT
INTERPRETATION WE CAN ALL BE ON
THE SAME PAGE. THREE SINGLE TIME
THEY LANDED AT THE SAME
CONCLUSION ON THESE ISSUES AND I
THINK AND- THING TO BE. THE.
BUT IT DOES LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
SCARCE LOCAL AND STATE RESOURCES
THAT ARE BEING SPENT GETTING TO
THE BOTTOM OF WHAT EXACTLY
EIGHTY AWESOME TENDING SO IN
CONCLUSION CHURN MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL TODAY AND FOR SUPPORTING
ABUNDANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE CERTAINTY ON TIMELINES
FOR HOMEOWNERS WHICH WE KNOW IS
IMPORTANT IMPROVE THE CLARITY OF
EXISTING LAW AS IT APPLIES TO
THESE COMMON IN BIG. IT TIONS.
SURE THAT CITY TO. RESTRICT WORD
AT SITTING GUIDANCE FROM THE
STATE ON HOW TO PROCESS THESE
PERMITS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH A NICE PRESENTATION THE
STRUGGLE IN OTHER. I DON'T SAID
THAT THERE WAS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY- DO EVERYONE NOT
OTHERS THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I'M BRIANNA'S
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. STEPHEN%
SENSOR WITH BRANSON ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING ACTION COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. I SING NINE ARE
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. SEEING THOSE ARE THE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SINGER I BUDGETS HOUSE MINORITY
IN MOTION HERE. SEVEN OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY US AND REMEMBER
ALMOST A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- JUST
STATING THAT- THIS BILL WILL AS
STATED WILL OFFER CLEAR CONCISE
IN CERTAIN- PARAMETERS FOR
BUILDING A D. USE IN JUST A LAST
THOUGHT ON THAT. MY HOME
PARTICULARLY WE HAVE NOT MOVED
FORWARD IN BUILDING IN A DO YOU
BUT WE'RE INTERESTED AND I
THINK. THIS IS A VERY CREATIVE
WAY FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE HAVE
THEIR ADULTS A- ADULTS OUT OF
THEIR HOMES TO MAYBE WE ARE
LOOKING AT POSSIBLY MOVING IN
TODAY DO YOU EVENTUALLY AND
REALLY DOING THAT AGING IN PLACE
AND I THINK. AS PEOPLE START TO
SEE THE- THESE OPPORTUNITIES IN
THEIR OWN SINGLE FAMILY HOME
THAT THEY OWN THERE MAY BE- MORE
OPPORTUNE THESE FOR. DO THESE
CREE SOLUTION. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU KNOW IF
YOU EACH YEAR WE DO BILLS IN
THIS BUILDING RIGHT AND WE THINK
WE HAVE THE PERFECT BILL BUT
THEN WE NEED TO DO THINGS LIKE
CLARIFICATION AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR BILL IS
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THAT FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THIS MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. I
THINK WE ARE. I LACKEY I'D-
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BERNHARDT NOT VOTING RAMOS.
RUBBLE SIDE OF THE RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SIGHED
VOEPEL RIGHT VOEPEL I THINK.
RIGHT NOW TEXAS BUT NOT WITHOUT
REVENUE ELSEWHERE WE'RE WAITING
FOR ONE MORE PERSON FOR VOTING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT- MISS BONTA
YOU HAVE BEEN A ROCK STARS IN
THEIR- WE'LL DO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. AB. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY.
THE REQUESTED. IS THE VEHICLE
PROTECTION. WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY GOOD EARLY EVENING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL AND
THE DEDICATED WORK OF YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AS AMENDED AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND THE CITIES WITH THOSE WITHIN
THESE. I PROPERTIES INTO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY DIRECTING
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
IDENTIFY THEIR BLIGHTED
PROPERTIES AND DEVELOP A PLAN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS. LOCAL COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS AND LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO REVITALIZE THOSE
PROPERTIES AND RETURN THEM TO
COMMUNITY HANDS. ADDITIONALLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ASKED TO
IDENTIFY BARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM AND
WORK TO REMOVING TO REMOVE THM.
THIS PROGRAM SPRINGS FROM A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PILOT IN THE CITY OF
RICHMOND WHICH I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH WHERE THE SPONSORS
TRANSFORM TO BLIGHTED PROPERTIES
INTO NEW HOMES FOR THE FIRST
TIME HOME BUYERS AND IN THE
PROCESS REDUCED CRIME AND THE
COSTS TO THE CITY FOR AFFECTED
NEIGHBORHOODS. MEMBERS
HOMEOWNERSHIP REMAINS A VERY
DISTANT DREAM FOR FAR TOO MANY
AS THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP
CONTINUES TO WIDEN WITH EACH
GENERATION. AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF HOMES ARE BOUGHT UP BY
INVESTORS WITH NO CONNECTION TO
THE COMMUNITY WITH THIS BILL WE
ARE RECLAIMING ABANDONED
NEGLECTED HOMES AND RENTAL IN
REDLINED NEIGHBORHOODS. FOR THE
BENEFITS OF THE COMMUNITY TO
KEEP OUR STREETS SAFE AND TO
START BUILDING AND REBUILDING
BLACK AND BROWN WELL FOR
OURSELVES AND OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU AND AS WITNESSES WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE ADAM BRIONNA CEO
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
WILL BE READING THE TESTIMONY OF
NIKKI BEASLEY. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. NEED HOUSING SO. AND
JIM BAKER ON TIME FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE RICHMOND COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADAM
BRIONNA SAID I'M CEO OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS A
NONPROFIT POLICY ORGANIZATION
WORKING TO CLOSE THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP THROUGH HOUSING
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND SMALL BUSINESS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. THANK YOU TO
CHAIR AGUIAR-CURRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR HEARING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL TODAY AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA.
I'M HERE TODAY IS A BILL
SPONSORED TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
AND TO READ A STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF MY COSPONSORED FRIEND
NIKKI BEASLEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF RICHMOND NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSING
SERVICES. RICHMOND NEIGHBORHOOD
HOUSING SERVICES ARE ARE CAST IS
A HOT APPROVED COUNSELLING
AGENCY AN INFILL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPER. OUR NHS HAS LEARNED
FIRSTHAND THE DIFFICULTY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE FORCE
HOUSING WITH PRIMARILY DUE TO
LACK OF SUBSIDY IN FINANCING FOR
THIS TYPE OF. FIVE THE REMEDY
ISSUE AND OUR MEETING COST COSTA
THROUGH. PROGRAM WHERE FIRST
BLIGHTED VACANT PROPERTY WILL BE
IDENTIFIED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THAT WAS TO PROPERTY SHARE.
THE DEVELOPER'S. SECOND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
REGIONAL CHARITABLE FOUNDATIONS
AND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
CREATE NEW FUNDING MODELS TO
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE OUTCOME OF
THESE TWO MEASURES WILL BE
FORMALLY APPLY BLIGHTED VACANT
HOMES IT RE HAPPENED SOUL TO
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES. ALONG
WITH INCREASED REVENUES FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY IS BASED ON A PROVEN
MODEL FIRST DEMONSTRATED IN THE
CITY OF RICHMOND AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHICH BENEFITTED WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES AND FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS AS WELL SEEMINGLY
INTRACTABLE BLIGHT AND CODE
ENFORCEMENT PROBLEMS. I HOPE
THIS COMMITTEE WILL VOTE TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT PILOT
WHICH WILL INCREASE
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND WEALTH
BUILDING BUT DECREASING BLIGHTED
DORMANT PROPERTIES IN ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. A MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S JIM BACKER OF THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE RICHMOND
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND RCF
CONNECTS. WHICH IS THE REGIONAL
FOUNDATION FOR A CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK AS
A SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY. NOW IN
RICHMOND WILL LAUNCH THE PILOT
WE HAD OVER TWO HUNDRED BOARDED
UP SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN THE
CITY AND THESE WERE COSTING OUR
CITY. ABOUT POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR JUST TO KEEP
THE BOARDED UP. AND THAT MEANS
THEY CONTINUE TO DECLINE. THERE
WAS NO FINANCING TO RECLAIM THE
SMALL LOT INFILL SITE SO WE IN
THE CITY CREATED OUR OWN. WE
LOOKED AT A MODEL WHERE THE CITY
WAS A CONDUIT ISSUER OF THE
INVESTMENT. WE IS THE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION WHERE THE BAR WERE
AND WE BROUGHT INVESTORS TO THE
TABLE WHO. FOR THE RETURN OF
THEIR PRINCIPAL AND A SMALL RATE
OF RETURN WE'RE HAPPY TO INVEST
IN THESE PROJECTS. SO MANY
CITIES DEAL WITH WITH PLOY AND
BLIGHTED PROPERTIES IN AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY WILL HELP OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT WE SERVE
BRING THESE PROPERTIES BACK. AND
OPEN UP THE OPPORTUNITIES THEY
HAVE FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP
PARTICULARLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
CITY CODE ENFORCEMENT TEAMS AS
CRITICAL PARTNERS PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION ON AND ACCESS TO THE
BLIGHTED ABANDONED HOMES SO THAT
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONE DEVELOPED
IN RICHMOND. CAN EVALUATE
REQUIRE REHAB AND THEN SELL THEM
TO GRADUATES OF THE LOCAL HAD
CERTIFIED FIRST TIME HOME BUYER
GRANTS. AND SAYS SURE THE IMPACT
TO THE CITY OF RICHMOND ON THE
PILOT. SO OVER THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD OF THE PILOT. WE WERE
THESE CODE FORSMAN COSTS BY OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. WE PAID IN THE
RECLAMATION OF THESE PROPERTIES
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
UNPAID PROPERTY TAXES AND COULD
FORCE MILLIONS. WE PROVIDED SIX
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOCAL SPENDING. WE INCREASED
ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE BY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. AND ACCORDING TO THE NBA
THE HOMEOWNERS NATIONAL BUILDING
ASSOCIATIONS IS MADE THE
HOMEOWNERS THAT WE BROUGHT INTO
THE COMMUNITY. PROVIDE OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR
AND IMPACT IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
AND WE HAD A FIFTY PERCENT. AND
SOMETIMES GREATER REDUCTION IN
CRIME IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS. AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY WILL ALLOW
OTHER COMMUNITIES IN THIS PILOT
TO RECLAIM THIS DILAPIDATED
HOUSING STOCK AND RECAP SIMILAR
BENEFITS. WE HAVE INTEREST FROM
K INVESTORS WITH ABOUT TEN
MILLION CAPITAL SITTING IN THE
WINGS FOR THIS PILOT HAS
DESCRIBED IN THE BILL THAT
INCLUDES CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND
OTHER CITIES IN THE COUNTY. THE
CITY OF ALEJO'S WHICH I REALIZE
IS NOT PART OF THIS BILL BUT IS
INTERESTED CITY OF HAYWARD THE
CITY OF OAKLAND AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY. AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
WILL PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK FOR
THIS IMPORTANT THING STRATEGY
AND OPEN UP THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST CHALLENGING
HOUSING ENVIRONMENTS AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE THIS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THIS CAMANCHE BOARD.
BUT I'M SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TURN UP IN A CAR HOW
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA BE IN
SUPPORT. YOUR MOM ED WITH LAST
PUBLIC AFFAIRS- FOR OF JESUS. I
TOTALLY AT ALL OF THESE TO LIVE
OUT OKAY FOR HABITAT OF HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA REGIONAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES INITIATIVE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LATE IN THE
DAY WE WILL NOT REMEMBER WHAT
JUST HAPPENED. OKAY ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. SING NOT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY YEAH
I- NO ONE LIKES BLOOD PRESSURE.
BUT ONE OF MY CONCERNS RIGHT NOW
AS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE-
DEFINITION OF BLIGHT IS QUITE
BROAD. AND IF I CAN GET THAT
TIGHTENED UP YOU YOU WOULD GET
MY SUPPORT BECAUSE IT I DON'T
THINK FOR EXAMPLE I YOU HAVE TO
LIVE IN THE DESERT. AND BAKER
OWNS DON'T NECESSARILY PERCENT
LIGHT CONDITIONS- NOR DOES A NON
APPROVED PROPERTY SO. IF WE CAN
GET THAT TIGHTENED UP TO WHERE
IT'S- IT'S CLEARLY A BLIGHT
CONDITION THEN I WOULD BE
WILLING TO SUPPORT OF IT AS IT
STANDS NOW I'M NOT QUITE THERE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH. NO PROBLEM THERE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE THE SUGGESTIONS
OFFERED BY MR LACKEY AND MAKING
SURE TO CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE US
AROUND BLIGHTED PROPERTIES AND
WITH THAT AT WHATEVER WE CAN DO
IS A STATE TO INSURE THAT WE
HAVE A PATHWAY TO HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND A PATHWAY TO BEAUTIFUL
COMMUNITIES IS A- THING AND WITH
THAT RESPECT. I VOTE I WANT TO
PURCHASE PERSONALLY I THANK THE
CHAIR FOR SUGGESTING THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS IS A PART
WITH AS A PILOT SO THAT IT WILL
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO HAVE OUR
LOCAL OVERNMENTS REALLY BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE THE CAPACITY NEEDED TO
BE ABLE TO SUCCESS LEE REFER
PROGRAMS I THINK YOU YEAH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COLLABORATING
WITH THE COMMITMENT COMMITTEE ON
THE AMENDMENT A MECHANISM A PRO. THIS IS THE CBS. AND I CAN'T
WAIT FOR YEARS NOW OR SO LOOK AT
WHAT IT DOES AND WE'VE GOT WHOLE
STATE ON BOARD SO THANKS FOR
BRINGING AFFORD. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
LACKEY THAT VOTING BLOOM. BLOOM
I'M BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I'M RAMOS. LEVEL
SILENCE RIVAS. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS DI VOEPEL. NOBODY.
WILL TELL NOT VOTING. YOU HAVE
BY. OKAY WE CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO NOW IS-
THE RISK. OF A- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'VE GOT THE BILL ARNOLD
OPENED ITS WAY OUT SO WE ARE
GOING TO. GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
BILL PACKAGE HERE WE HAVE ONE
MEMBER MISSING AND BELIEVE. WHAT
IT WEEK OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GO THROUGH THIS WEEK
AND THEN WHEN SHE COMES SHE
REVERSE OF IT WILL WORK WILL
MAKE IT WORK OKAY. ALL RIGHT
LET'S START WITH A B. SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE IN THIS AREA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATION
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
LACKEY. NAQI ABSTAINED BLOOM
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH WHEN I
HEARD THAT I ROMMEL'S REBELS I
WAS RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS SIGHED VOEPEL
NOTHING WILL TELL NOT VOTING YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE ZERO
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE VÀ OF THE ROLE OPEN.
OKAY WE'RE ON IT AB NINE ZERO
EIGHT AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
QUIRK-SILVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. BLOOM
LOW I. YOU CURRENTLY HAVE SIX
BOTH OF SIX BOATS THE FEDERAL
OPEN AB TWO TWO TWO ONE. THREE
THE PLAN WILL BE. AB TWO TWO TWO
ONE ITEM FOR SILVA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS A MAN TO APPROPRIATIONS
. CURRENTLY A SIX ZERO
THREE OF US IS THE MISERABLE ALL
RIGHT. I REMEMBER FIVE EIGHT B.
NINETEEN TEN CRISTINA GARCIA.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
PROCREATION THE VOTE CURRENTLY
IS FOR TWO- THREE OF US I START
WITH MISSING ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO A- ITEM NUMBER SIX. NINETY
TEAM. TWENTY FIVE SANTIAGO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY FOR THREE. APSIDAL T.
VOTERS IS JUST THOSE THREE OF US
OKAY. OTHER NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY THREE SANTIAGO
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS VOTERS CURRENTLY. FOR TWO. WE JUST
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
NO THREE OF US THIRTY EIGHT
POINT THREE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
FOUR THREE ON THE BILL. I WILL
GO TO ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY ONE BERMAN. THE
MOTION IS CURRENTLY TO PASS A
MAN TO APPROPRIATION THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS FIVE. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS. WE NOW HAVE SIX
ZERO WE HAVE SIX ZERO WAY FOR
THE REMEMBER- THIS. ITEM NUMBER
TEN JUST JUST IN READING OKAY. I
AM NUMBER A LOVE OF THE CITY
TWELVE. TWO THREE TWO THREE
THREE FOUR TWO AB TWO THREE
THREE FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
A MAN TO APPROPRIATION
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY
IRAQI. LACKEY NOW FLU FLU I'VE
BOERNER HORVATH. THIS IS THE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWO THREE
THREE FOUR. BEFORE THAT. UHHUH
HELLO THIS IS A WEIRD- EXCUSE
THREE WE NEED A MOTION ON A
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWO THREE THREE
FOUR MY CORRECT WE NEED. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY A MYSTERY OF US THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ONE AB TWO TWO TWO AB TWO
THREE THREE FOUR WICKS. BUT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A BENCH
APPROPRIATION AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY LACKEY
NOBLE HI LOU I JUST HEARD A
HARDBACK. WHERE ARE THAT NO ROB
. RAMOS I RIVAS. THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
NO VOEPEL NO THAT IS A FIVE
THREE OKAY I'M GOING TO STEP
BACK ON ITEM NUMBER ONE WE'RE
REPORT- WORKING AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND SO WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE NAZARIAN.
SO OKAY REVENUE RUSSIAN BY
ROBERT RIVAS SISTER OF FIVE.
MINUTES MYSTERON LOS. OKAY OKAY
SO GO AHEAD AND CREATE A RECORD
OKAY AGUIAR-CURRY HAI
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M LACKEY LACKEY
NOT VOTING. BLOOM BLOOM I
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I'M RAMOS RAMOS I WAS RIVAS
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I HAVE A PELL. BUT
TELL NOT VOTING YOU HAVE TO
FORCE. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO NINE
SELF AND THAT BILL IS OUT OKAY
LET'S JUMP BACK WHO DON'T GO
BACK TO LINE HERE WE ARE AT-
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN MIA BONTA
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS A MAJOR
APPROPRIATIONS. THREE OF US FIVE
THREE OF US SIGN FOR THE SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE MULLIN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATION. LOOSER- ROMMEL'S
. WELL AS I. ROBERT REID-
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI YOU
NOW HAVE EIGHT ZERO THE BILLS
OUT EIGHT ZERO. I ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWO TWO NINE FIVE
BLOOM. THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
MAN THE VOTE IS FOR ONE. BLACK
I'LL GO BACK YOU VOTED
BOERNER HORVATH. FIVE RIGHT
CORRECTION NINE OKAY
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I. SIX ONE SIX ONE
THE BILL IS OUT. I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN A. B. TWO THREE THREE
NINE BLOOM. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A MAN CURRENT VOTE IS FOR.
THREE OF US THREE OF US FIVE
FIVE THE BILL THAT FIVE ZERO. I
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY BLOOM. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR THE VOTE
IS CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS-
GRAB HIM. EVERY INTO. SOMEONE
TEXT OF. IN ORDER TO GET INTO
THE- WITH THE ROADRUNNERS FIVE
ZERO BUT THIS FIVE C. SO IS OUT
BUT OKAY THE BECOMES THE IT
COMES BACK UP HI ROBERT I ON AB
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU. FOR THE
SIX ZERO OKAY THAT'S NOT SIX
ZERO. THINK WE JUST HAVE A FEW
FOR LOU DEGREE DO. YOU THINK-
RENDON CONSECUTIVE- AND THAT'S
LOSE. YEAH THREE OF US
THREE OF US I EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO SIX CALENDAR. OKAY LET'S
FINISH UP. FOR THE REST OF THE-
OKAY THE- SEVEN GO. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE MOTIONIS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH ROOF
OVER. QUIRK-SILVA THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIZE SEVEN ZERO
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO. THE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWO TWO TWO ONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A BENCH
APPROPRIATIONS THREE OF US
THREE OF US I SEVEN ZERO OKAY A
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO. AB
NINETEEN TEN- I REMEMBER FIVE
CRISTINA GARCIA. MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS THREE OF US
SIDE BY TWO. BILLS UP FIVE TO.
BUT I REMEMBER SIX. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE SANTIAGO MOTIONS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE FIVE BUT VOTE
CHANGE. THE VOTE CHANGE ON
NINETY THREE BY BIRD A HARDBACK
VOTE CHANGE NOTE HI- TANGLED
SIZE THAT IS SIX TWO FOR ABOUT.
SIX TO. I DON'T SEVEN TWO SIX
FIVE THREE WITHOUT THEM. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
VOTERS CURRENTLY FOR THREE
THREE OF US I DECIDE. FIVE THREE
FIVE THREE. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
ONE HOUR TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE ITEM ON NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY ONE BERMAN
THREE OF US THREE OF US SIZE
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT
- ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS TO PASS A
MENTOR PROBES THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I SEVEN NO. EIGHT
I'M SORRY EIGHT- HEY. IN THE. TO
THE TO. PUT BOTH OVER ROBERT.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. BUT BECAUSE WE
DID LATE. WE'RE JUST DOUBLE
CHECKING YOUR MYSTERY OF US
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
OKAY FEEL BETTER. BOB YEAH THANK
ZERO OKAY. AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE AS A DO PASSED
APPROPRIATION ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT ZERO. THAT WAS- WAS
THE BUILDING. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE OUT EIGHT ZERO.
OKAY IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANT TO DO TODAY HERE. OKAY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEES ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
EVERYONE.